as chair of the House Education
committee I find that dat to the state
of emergency declared by the governor as
to resoling the covid-19 pandemic and in
accordance with house room 67 and the
governance emergency order number 12
pursu to executive order
2020-4 this public body authorized to
meet
electronically this is a public hearing
of bills referred to the education
committee executive session oning
legislation please not there's no Loc
to observe and
listenting however with theer I
confirming that all members of the
committee and select legislative staff
have the ability to communicate
contemporaneously during this meeting
through the zoom electronic meeting
platform the public has access to
contemporaneously listen and if
necessary participate in this meeting by
the zoom platform or by telephone all
necessary Act access information has
been made available in the house
calendar and through the electronic
calendar on the general court website
the notice for this meeting complies
with house rules in RSA
91-1 anyone who has a problem accessing
27136 or email HCS
l.st
new.
Us in the event that the public is
unable to access the meeting the meeting
will be adjourned and rescheduled I want
to introduce the staff that are on the
meeting assisting us sen for four
committee
researchers please note that all votes
that are taken during this meeting shall
be done by roll call V start the meeting
by taking a roll call of attendance when
also please St also State whether there
is anyone in the room with you during
this meeting which is required the right
Mesi here in the committee room
representative here in the committee
room representa L here in the committee
room represent m in the
house representative hson
here in the house in the
house and
here at home in Salsbury
yes are you at home yes I am alone thank
you representative Leon here in the
committee room representa s here also in
the represent Miler I am here in Kuka
Hopkinson here in the
roomes Carell home in
Manchester Tanner
home and George's Mills with Raven my
rescue
doges uh home alone here in conquered
represent mull home here in
Bedford
him
repres wood here in Senate Conway New
Hampshire with my wife in the building
and my dog barking in the
background representative lad I'm here
lob one
pres we have one at this time uh today's
meeting is to for the purpose of hearing
continuing the hearings on
hb20 uh before I get in and start
recognizing folks to testify I'd like to
remind all the folks that are wanting to
testify if you have written testimony
please submit that written testimony to
the clerk or to our committee
researchers um this will really help
expedite our moving law and help
up um also uh if you are here to speak
and you're going to speak on an issue
and the content of what you want to
address has already been alluded to or
spoken would you just please reference
that and not um go into any further
explanation um also if you have written
testimony that you submitted
please please summarize rather than
reading it so with that I'd like to open
up our Committee hearing on
hb20 this is a bill that references the
education freedom of accounts uh
represent hops who's the first to speak
today our first speaker is Kate Baker
deur and she has been promoted to
panelist and we have a followup that's
GNA be coming behind that we do uh that
will be Barrett Christina from the
School Board Association okay so we have
two people that are G be speaking right
from the beginning we're got Kate Baker
and then from the school boards
Association representing the elected
officials School local school board
members will be bar Christina welcome
Kate hi how's my volume can everyone
hear me great so um it's been tough year
you know for all of us this pandemic has
really exacerbated the challenges of our
most vulnerable children I'm Kate Baker
Demers I'm a Manchester resident born on
the west side I'm the director of
children's scholarship fund New
Hampshire I've been running the
education Tech tax credit scholarship
program since its Inception in
2013 um dotting every eye and Crossing
every tea year after year for the
benefit of low-income children in New
Hampshire so they can get an education
that they otherwise couldn't afford um
we're efficient and effective at
Children's scholarship fund with
annually between 90 and 94 cents on
every dollar going directly to kids um I
drive a Toyota
Corolla in
2016 we were lucky to become part of
children's scholarship fund National so
we do have the infastructure and systems
of a large organization we conduct an
independent audit annually our 990s
financial statements um and annual
reports are all open and public um our
Department of Revenue annual reports are
also rigorous open available and public
um and we share with Pride where every
child attends school every scholarship
child um and what every family does with
our um homeschool scholarships also we
have a fourstar charity Navigator rating
which is the highest possible rating
that a nonprofit can have and we also
have the highest possible score that one
can get um for accountability and
transparency this fall at Children's
scholarship fund New Hampshire we were
able to help six 626 low-income children
in need with scholarships which was a
hundred more than we could help last
year but for perspective this last fall
we had 30 kids on our weit list and this
fall there was 800 children that we were
unable to serve they were um children of
single moms or dads who needed to go to
work in person you know to put food on
their table like lnas and delivery
drivers and grocery store employees they
were children with special needs for
whom remote therapy just wasn't working
at all uh they were M medically fragile
children who couldn't go into a
classroom setting that the parents had
fear that the children would be um in
danger in a classroom setting and they
wanted to stay home and all those people
were in addition to our normal kids that
we see in any given year usually those
are kids that are bullied and need to go
to a different School setting they might
be kids that are well below grade level
and the parent is looking for a smaller
class size for them or they might be
families with special needs who are just
at the end of their rope and want to opt
to do something completely
different um these families are normal
families and then we saw all these other
families because of the pandemic so it's
been a really tough year
hb20 gives us the opportunity all of us
the opportunity to serve these children
and really that's what we're all here
for is to serve the children of New
Hampshire I'm just going to point out a
couple of things in the bill that I
think are of note that haven't been
brought up by anyone else um who's been
talking about it and that is the the
total transparency around the use of the
funds it's very clear what you can use
it for and it will be very clear in the
reporting and accountability what those
funds are used for I thought also the
fact that it requires a system for
rating and reviewing education providers
that's public will be a wonderful piece
and service to the state where you can
go and see how education providers who
they are and what they're doing and what
do people think about them I think
that's a really important piece of this
bill um I also um noted that there's
auditing of every account and I thought
that was a really good piece of this
bill I like how the bill requires the
scholarship organization to use a
financial Tech payment platform I know
that class wallet is also here today and
they are ready to share with you how
that works and the accountability and
transparency built into that payment
platform and the fact that this bill
specifies doing something that's
familyfriendly and also fraud prevention
I think is really important um the fact
that the State Board of Ed further after
this bill makes the rules I think will
make it really clear how to run the
program and I appreciate that that is in
there I also o um noticed the uh
rigorous annual reporting and that
there's legislative oversight and that
those legislators are elected I thought
that elected legislator oversight piece
of this was also good and so for me you
know hb20 and education Freedom accounts
will give us the opportunity really all
of us to serve New Hampshire children
who otherwise are struggling and so
children's scholarship fund supports
this
legislation
thank you very much uh Kate Baker the M
um do you are you willing to take any
questions from members of the committee
I can take as many questions as people
want to ask me absolutely we're try to
keep time down because we have a whole
host
people I'm sure you do I'm sure you do
I'm available to all of you anytime as
you know happy to answer anything give
you my cell number you
know thank you m shair and thank you
Kate for your your work in this area uh
I want to ask what type of expenses do
cover thank you so much that's a great
question so what we see with our
existing we do have almost 200
homeschoolers in our current education
tax credit scholarship program using a
homeschool scholarship and the families
I I did I do have a list of that and
they have um
particularly about 3% spend money on
tutoring about 7% spend money on online
classes textbooks are about 15% of the
purchases um technology Hardware
Chromebooks are about eight% of the
purchases education therapies about 2%
testing fees about
5% college classes and again remember
you can use this for a college class but
only if you haven't graduated from high
school yet so these aren't actually
college student they're high school
students taking a college course and
that was
1% um Public School tuition was about 2%
so people are buying classes and courses
online for example we have a student um
in Lowden on a farm who goes to online
school at Stanford University he was an
advanced child who needed a more
accelerated curriculum and so he's
technically a homeschooler even though
he's a full-time online Schooler and so
we see that we see people purchasing
courses and classes there are some um
co-ops that have opened um there's one
in Manchester where families can
purchase classes for their homeschool
classes there's also a a Learning Center
in do called big big fish and I think
you actually heard from one of those
students um who was on the meeting last
time talking about his experience there
at bigfish and at big fish is a place
where you're a homeschooler but you
purchase courses and classes and
advising from the school and so we see
that um people also do purchase music
classes um what else do I see here music
lessons learning
supplies mad science
class so it's been a really fun
opportunity to be able to provide
low-income families with this you know
sometimes with a homeschooler they're
giving up an entire person's income
capability to stay home and educate
their child and so to be able to help
them with these curriculum type things
and courses you know I see a New
Hampshire history class here to be able
to provide that for families is really
except ctional and meaningful so thanks
Moffett yes
represent thank you Mr chair thanks than
my
question I'd like to find out how do you
see that this bill would
impact um minority kids and
disadvantaged kids you see that this
is we just expand on the idea choice and
the charter school already started
sure that's a that's a good question so
the our existing tax credit program our
scholarship program is one of the most
diverse programs in the state so while
the state percentages are 90% white in
New Hampshire and then
10% um people of color our program is
about
78% people that are white and
22% um people of color and so we do find
that many families come to us because
they might be experiencing some form of
discrimination in their school they tell
us um that happens to them they tell us
that they experience racism and that's
why they come to us and so the fact that
a program exists where a family who's
experiencing something like that can get
help I think is really important and so
um when you're creating education
Freedom accounts yes you are creating an
opportunity for a family who otherwise
is experiencing discrimination to come
or bullying um and and go to a school
where they want to or a building that's
safe for them um there was a gleon
report that they put out um that said
that LBGTQ CH kids are the most bullied
63% of those kids in schools are bullied
um and that is the top reason that
people come to us now is because they're
experiencing bullying or discrimination
and so putting a program like education
Freedom accounts into place does
directly help those
kids thank you very much are there
for yeah thank you very much Mr chair um
would um um and thank you very much U
Miss Baker for um I'm sorry U for taking
my um my question no problem just um uh
was wondering based on the um the the
the estimated um uh State costs that the
uh uh LBA has um um has put forward how
much revenue do the scholarship
organizations look to potentially
receive as a result of hosal 20 you're
asking the administrative cost right now
we run between 90 and 94 cents goes to
kids so that would be between six and
10% of our cost what happens
representative luno is if something is
larger it's more efficient when
something is smaller it's usually less
efficient in the nonprofit space there's
a lot of discussion around um 10% being
kind of the requirement of a baseline
for a Federal grant for example to run
well they'll say you should use 10% as
your Baseline there's some discussion in
the nonprofit space also about making
sure that you're not being so narrow
that you don't run well and so we do a
really good job currently with that
946 um overall at Children's scholarship
fund running really efficiently and
we'll work to run as efficiently as
possible I'm not going to upgrade my
Corolla anytime soon I want to be able
to send all the money to kids if I can
and so we'll run efficiently but that is
a really reasonable expectation that
some somewhere between 6% and 10% is
going to be the cost to run the program
and that's super efficient and gold
standard for nonprofits I know for
example Easter Seals in New Hampshire
runs 9010 nine 90% goes right to the
programs in families and 10% is for
their administrative so I feel like
that's pretty reasonable and safe safe
guess and and you know I'll run it as
efficiently as possible for sure if I
run this type of
program uh followup Mr chair
so um so thanks very much for that so
that would be somewhere between 6 to 10%
of the um $ 74.8 million that the that
the LBA has um has looked at I guess I
that doesn't sound like a reasonable
projection well it's what they it's what
they they emailed me so so in other stes
but I've got a question I've got a
question I've got a question sorry so
question is is would you be interested
in learning more about a bill
particularly being from Manchester would
you be interested in learning more about
Senate Bill uh 158 which with with no
additional um impact on on property
taxes to Manchester um uh property
taxpayers would direct um almost that
same number close to $80 million in
additional State funding to the
Manchester School District would you be
interested in learning more about that
bill I mean I love reading everything
representative luno and having wonderful
conversations I I think that it's
families use an education Freedom
account it does increase the per pupil
money that the district has for all the
kids that they have there and so I I
think we're talking about apples and
oranges I'm not quite sure where you're
going with your with your question okay
thank you yeah you're welcome uh further
um
okay um I was wondering
how how this is going to avoid the
mistakes of Arizona as far as widescreen
televisions and stuff like
that so Arizona recently in the past two
years has moved their families to class
wallet and um it's standard now
understanding for anyone running these
programs Nationwide that that's the way
to do it initially Arizona used debit
cards where they tried to track spending
and that doesn't really make sense using
class wallet is really the way to go
because every expense can be
pre-approved and I know class wallet is
here today on this call to show you that
so you can see how the expenses are
preapproved by a real human instead of
being some sort of mechanical and the
the platform exists really to do that
and then to report down to the skew so
the transparency around that is really
good you're going to be able to see down
to the skew what every family does with
the money using class wallet and the
administrator will be able to
pre-approve every expense and there I
know class wallet's here to show you
that so you'll be able to see that
representative today yeah you're
welcome uh thank you very much Mr chair
and thank you Miss Baker for being here
my pleasure currently uh the funds
you're receiving uh are pre-tax dollars
uh from businesses is that correct you
could be now a business um or an
individual it's against business profits
tax business Enterprise tax and interest
in dividends tax so someone makes a
donation to the scholarship fund after
they've applied to Department of Revenue
then they can get the credit after they
make the donation but that's the
existing mechanism that we have yes HB
hb20 is dealing is directly from a
taxpayers uh money that would go to your
state yeah you're talking about the
State adequacy dollars following the
child wherever they go yeah absolutely
yeah could you could you tell could you
inform the uh committee please of your
current grants that you're providing how
many of those are going to um religious
schools please that's a great question I
don't have it broken out like that I
just have a list of all the schools
where the kids are going and so it's
Unity Christian School Meeting House
montauri Jesse Remington High School
Claremont Christian Academy New England
Classical Academy Trinity Christian
School Shaker Road School Bishop Brady
High School St John Regional School fors
Christian Academy St Thomas aquinus St
Mary Academy Big Fish Learning Community
Dublin Christian School Mountain Shadows
School building block Commons salv
Regina Hampstead Academy Sacred Heart
School Bradford Christian Academy the
beach Hill School presentation of Mary
Academy Victory High School manad
Waldorf School St Joseph's Regional
School Laconia Christian Academy Holy
Trinity School Acton Academy Mount Royal
Academy North St Francis of aisi
Southern New Hampshire montau Holy
Family Academy Mount Zion Christian
School Trinity High School North and
montauri St Benedict Academy Mount St
Mary Academy St Katherine School St
Joseph's Regional Junior High School
Cardinal lroy Academy Kimble Union
Academy South Marram Christian Academy
Bishop girton High School NASA Catholic
Regional High School St Christopher
Parish School Newport
montauri Cornerstone Christian Academy
Crossroads Christian School Green Valley
School the wells School Heritage
Christian School St Elizabeth Sean
School s Bonnie School Tri City
Christian Academy Mount Royal Academy
Tilton School high moing school pin hill
Waldorf School and then there's 194
homeschoolers thank you very much for
that information my
pleasure
Tanner um thank you for taking my
question Miss Baker um I was wondering
if you could uh if the giving andg
goinging Alliance is that uh is set up
by the christiany basically is still
part of the children's scholarship
fund uh that's a separate organization
and they actually don't have any staff
representative Tanner so I don't know
what their plans are
could I have have a followup on that
please um
so they are though approved to put out
these um vouchers as well as the other
scholarships yes we do get reapproved
every year and so they were approved
like we were um at the beginning of the
fiscal year to do scholarships for this
year but we're all only approved for one
year and then we reapply every year base
on our compliance with the law and
turning in our 05s on time and
resubmitting an application so one does
get reapproved every fiscal year and do
you know what percentage they
take I don't
know no I'm sorry I couldn't answer that
um who would we contact to find that
information out you actually can look at
the reports they're on the department of
revenues website um if you go to the
Department of revenues website and you
click on education tax credit you can
see all of the public reports that have
been published from last this year all
the way back to the beginning and so you
could really just look at it it's it's
public
information um it does seem like they're
part of your organization on the on some
of those reports though the ones so I
did use to help them in the beginning
when the organization started they did
not know how to do the work and so I did
help them in the beginning to learn to
do education tax credit scholarships I
mean 77g is also a 11 page law with
requirements and so I did help them so
you'll see in the beginning that we
filed reports together but now we've
gotten to the point where children's
scholarship fund is so large that I
don't have time to help anyone really
with anything else at all and they've
been able to to run that on their own
for years now thank you you're welcome
no one else listen if you start a
scholarship organization I'm too busy to
take one more question for you and okay
talk then we're GNA move on to next next
uh
speaker thank you Mr chairman uh and Mr
biger de M thank you much very simple
question I heard you um speak about the
different institutions that Mr M
represent mil asked you about is it
PO is it I believe it is it possible for
you to forward
forward the committee that list in
enrollment in each school please yeah
I'd love to yep happy to do that thanks
for my pleasure thank you Mr chair thank
you very much uh so we're going to thank
Kate Baker for being here today and
we're GNA move on now to Christina who
is representing the school boards
Association and all elected uh school
board members throughout our state of
New Hampshire welcome there
uh thank you very much uh chairman lad
good morning members of the committee
thank you for taking my testimony for
the record Barrett Christina executive
director of the New Hampshire school
boards Association uh we are in firm
opposition to house
bill2 um I I've in in preparing my
testimony um I thought it would be
helpful if we went through some actual
provisions of of the bill itself many of
the speakers uh last week um sort of
talked about their own personal
experiences and some of the broader
policies about um vouchers and
privatization so I'm going to walk
through some of the language of the bill
and and try to identify where there are
problems with the with the current
language where it may be contradictory
and then wrap that up um with some of
the larger policy concerns um of which
this bill has has many so I'm on page
one um of the bill um page one line 17
talks about an educ educational service
provider that provides educational
materials um educational materials is
not further defined um within the bill
um there's some stuff on page two um
that I'll get to in a little bit that
talks about tuition and tutoring um but
education materials is is is about as
broad-based of phrase as we could
possibly get um I'd like to know who
determines what the educational material
is is it the school is it the parent is
it the the educational um organization
ation that just spoke um some problems
with the eligible student language and
the definition of an eligible student I
just want to make sure I'm clear when it
says a resident of the state who was
eligible to enroll in a public
enrollement um in a public elementary or
secondary school so we're talking about
180,000 kids um that would potentially
be available for um this voucher this
this handout um of about $4 or $5,000
hours per person um I know they'll be
going to committee and fiscal notes so
I'm not going to get into that but I
just want to make sure that we're clear
that it's every kid that that's eligible
to attend public school is about 170
180,000 kids in the state um the other
question about that uh the definition of
an eligible student I'm on page one line
26 it says um you know eligible student
including a sibling of a student with a
with an education Freedom account um
does that sibling also have to be a
resident of New Hampshire and meet the
initial criteria I don't think that's
very clear um because it's quite
possible um that we have siblings of
students um who live in a different
state dad may live in in in Dover or
summersworth with one child and mom may
live in Berwick or South Berwick Maine
with another child um we have families
with with stepchildren and and half
brothers and half siblings that from my
own experience may live in various parts
of the state or various parts of of of
of Maine or New Hampshire or
Massachusetts so I are we expanding that
to any sibling regardless of where they
live or does that sibling also have to
be a New Hampshire
resident definition um page one line 30
fulltime means more than 50% of
instructional time um 50% of what is
that a school day is that a a
homeschooling day is that a a school day
based on the the the resident District's
hours um it's sort of using the phrase
instructional time is also
counterintuitive to the Competency Based
education system um that New Hampshire
has been moving towards for the last 10
or 12 years where we're not counting
seat time to earn credits we're talking
about competencies and Mastery of
competencies so I'm not sure what um you
know I'm not sure what instructional
time means um does that mean that they
have to BU adhere by the minimum
standards which require 9990 hours for
high school over the course of a year
and less for for elementary schools um
I'm moving on to page two um line one um
a person where the student or the
educator are not physically present in
the traditional classroom I don't know
what traditional classroom means um when
you tell me a traditional classroom are
we talking about a little two two room
Schoolhouse and in the mountains um or
are we talking about um you know uh the
latest
um classrooms in in Dover High School
which was just built two or three years
ago so I don't know what that means um
I'm on page two now continuing down um
talking about some of the the qualifying
expenses um I'm looking um I'm on sub
paragraph D this is line 19 says
Services contracted for and provided by
a public school district Charter Public
School public Academy including but not
limited to individual classes curricular
activities and programs one of the great
ironies with this bill is that public
schools provide these services for free
um and now we're giving money away to
parents to turn around and Reby them it
sounds like we're going to be paying for
the same Services twice whether or not
that's uh Educational Services Physical
Therapy special education services but
the services are are essentially if if
you're going to a public school and you
need those Services guess what parents
don't have to pay for them
um continuing down I'm on page line P
again page two line 25 of paragraph F
computer hardware internet connectivity
and other technological services and
devices that are used to help meet the
students educational
needs I'm going to try and not get testy
but this is a little bit insulting
considering that we have a lot of
schools that are still going remote and
when those children needed desk when
those children needed laptops and
devices it was the public schools that
paid for them and it was the public
schools that worked with the internet
service companies to try and get
internet out there um you know and how
about our teachers there's nothing in
law that requires a teacher has a laptop
or the internet at home but yet we know
our teachers were providing remote
instruction for the last 10 months and
are continuing to do so so if a kid
needs a computer and his rolled in the
public school um especially in times of
a pandemic and especially in times when
we're we're we're changing educational
models to meet the needs of kids
again local taxpayers are paying for
that the state isn't paying for that
local taxpayers are paying for that and
now we're giving them additional money
to go buy these sorts of things
um uh line 27 on page two educational
software and
applications is that education
applications or just applications
there'll be paying for Angry Birds um
and and and games to play I don't I
don't know what that means
either um line 32 tuition or fees or
other summer education programs what's
an educational program is that any sort
of summer camp does there have to be a
curriculum for a summer camp does it
have to relate to reading wrath and
reading um writing and arithmetic again
it's it's vague and and and if not who
decides who decides if it's if it's an
educational summer program is it the
scholarship organization is it some
level of oversight by the department of
educ
um these are all continuing questions
with the bill that simply don't have any
answers I'm moving on to page three um
uh line two again these are some of the
things that you can pay for fees for
transportation pay to a fee for service
TR uh Transportation provider for the
student to travel to and from an
educational Ser service provider again
these are paid for by public schools
already if a child needs to get on a bus
to go receive some sort of special
services um public schools are already
paying for that so again this is just
another example where if we're giving
out free money giving out a voucher to
people we're going to be paying for the
same service twice um that does not seem
like an efficient way to be spending
taxpayer money uh all the other things
um
to the things I talked about these these
qualifying educational expenses um one
of the larger concerns nhba has with
this B bill is whether or not these
Education Service Providers are required
to undergo criminal background checks
the same way um anybody that steps into
a public school to provide Education
Services is required to undergo a
criminal background check um further um
are they going to be required to adhere
to the the teacher or the educator code
of conduct that the Department of
Education um the state board has adopted
a couple years ago now I I understand
that the depart Department's really only
role is to cover certified Educators if
you hold a credential from the
Department um but it seems that if we're
going to be giving State money um to
these other education service providers
that they should at least be held to the
same standards at least as it comes to
child safety criminal background checks
I don't think is that much to ask and
adhering to um a code of conduct I don't
think is too much to ask
either um page three line 13 this is
where it says that the the EF F does not
constitute taxable income to the parent
I is that allowed some we need to check
with a tax attorney or the IRS on that I
don't know if a state statute can can
dictate what constitutes income and what
does not constitute income I presume
that that's a a federal is issue under
IRS
regulations
um I'm moving on to page
four um I'm online um
uh 17 I I this may be covered this may
not be covered elsewhere in the bill um
it talks about enrolling a full-time
student in the Resident School District
shall result in immediate suspension of
payment of additional funds um and if I
missed it maybe it isn't here but the
larger question is what happens to sort
of these unexpended funds does it is it
return back to the state does it go to
the school district where the the the
child resides who's receiving the the
voucher or I don't know does it stay
with a scholarship organization in their
account does it get back sent sent back
to the state or does it get sent to the
local school district if I miss that I
apologize but that's certainly a
has um moving on um I'm on page six line
seven says if an EFA student is free
from personal misconduct that student
shall be eligible for an EFA in the
future I don't know what that means by
personal misconduct um anybody with
anybody who has kids knows that um kids
are not free from personal
misconduct um which is why they're kids
and it's why it's responsibility of the
parents to to make sure that they're not
but I mean does that mean that the kid
had was suspended at a school does it
mean he got detention I don't I don't
know what that
means
um uh continuing up on um line 32 on
page six the scholarship organization
May adopt policies or procedures um it
seems that a sha would make more sense
there um it's also peculiar though that
we're putting sort of Ru making
Authority into the hands of of a private
entity um question the oversight um of
of of the scholarship organization
creating its own rules to run
itself um also on P this is on page six
and the top of page 7 I'm at line 36 on
page six um it says the scholarship
organization shall not include
discriminate against or otherwise
disadvantage any educational provider so
on and so forth with respect to the
religious character and
affiliation um including mission-based
practices
um by carving out the religious
exception in that line you're saying
that the scholarship organization can
discriminate for other basis um if
you're if if you don't want the
scholarship organization to discriminate
on any basis then you should then that
then that should be it um but by carving
out the religious carve out there I
think I think the implication is that
they can discriminate for other
purposes uh page seven line four uh the
scholarship organization and any
contractors shall comply with all
federal state laws regarding student
privacy um I I I I I'm not sure what
they mean by contractors are contractors
the service providers or are they
contractors that the the the the the
scholarship organization as a corporate
entity uses um the other challenge with
that just before the contractors and the
scholarship organization sort of jump
both feet in with respect to House Bill
20 um I'm going to interpret that as
meeting the scholarship organization any
contractors which I'm going to interpret
as as education service providers
um at this point need to comply with
House Bill
1612 um the cost time effort and
expertise that needed to um uh implement
the provisions of House Bill 1612 for
the newer members that was a very
significant data privacy bill um uh
sponsored by representative cordelli in
2018 I believe that was Sir and um nhba
was happy to help with representative
Cordell and house at in full legislature
to provide multiple uh training
opportunities and webinars and in-person
trainings for House Bill 12 but
um it was quite an effort school
districts are still um I think getting
up to speed on that but it was timely it
was costly it was expensive um so I just
want to make sure we're clear that
scholarship organizations and
contractors which may or may not include
the education service providers are also
required to comply with house B
uh um so page8 line
20 Education Service Providers shall be
given maximum freedom to provide for the
educational needs of vfa students
without government control I I think
that this really sort of sums up House
Bill 20 and and all the other voucher
bills we're giving away money and
there's no
oversight uh I would think that if we're
giving away State money public money um
you know adequacy grants uh that there
should be some level of government
control and governmental
oversight
um so those those are just some of the
highlights nhsda has identified um with
the bill there are some of the larger
policy concerns that nsba has the fiscal
note I know that the LBA did a fiscal
note the department did a fiscal note
reaching higher New Hampshire did a
fiscal note I'm not going to get into
the nitty-gritty of of of of those
people are going to believe what they
want to believe but at its most base
level if we're talking about 15 or
20,000 kids that are currently in
private schools and homeschooling right
now and and not even even if not a
single child in in currently enrolled in
public schools access this um we've got
about 20,000 kids in home schools and
and and private schooling I believe or
some of the the enrollment numbers
that's $80 million price tag just on
that um um remind you that we're arguing
over $50 million for school building Aid
when we know that the department has
reported that um you know building aid
needs across the state are about a
billion dollars um it seems odd that we
just want to you give away that much
money and we said without any government
oversight or control is the bill notes
um the other aspect to which I think is
concerning is that there's no
requirement these that these Education
Service Providers be New Hampshire
corporations so we could be giving a
voucher um for a kid to be go to school
out of state it seems that the very
least is a policy um standpoint the
committee might want to make sure that
state money is being spent in state for
state
students um and and last there's there's
two one aspect um one word that gets
floated around a lot with respect to to
these bills um and I'd like to provide a
little context and Clarity to that um
the word is accountability um we know
that you know uh opponents of House Bill
20 have said there's a lack of
accountability proponents of House Bill
20 have said that you know parents are
ultimately you know accountable for the
education of their child and school
districts are accountable to parents and
so on and so forth there's two kinds of
accountability that we're talking about
the first is going to what I'm going to
call Little a accountability in the
sense that school boards are accountable
to the taxpayers school boards are
accountable to the parents and the
children that are within their District
um you know anybody time we're spending
public money we're account accountable
to the public that level of
accountability what opponents of House
Bill 20 when when opponents of House
Bill 20 speak about accountability this
is big a accountability and that's the
requirements um both found in statute
Department of Education rules and the
New Hampshire Constitution that there be
an accountability system within our
public education that accountability
system is the Statewide assessment um
we've we've had some conversations about
the input-based accountability system
and the output based accountability
system on some of the other bills this
session um that's the accountability
that's lacking from this bill um our
public schools are required to file all
sorts of accountability um reports with
the Department of Education and and why
do they have to do that because it's
state money and if you're taking State
money certain strings come attached with
that so I just want to I wanted to
clarify that for the committee when
we're talking about
accountability in the educational
context we're not talking about the
little a accountability where school
boards are accountable to parents and
school boards are accountable to
taxpayers and things of that
accountability General accountability
we're talking big a accountability which
the law already requires public schools
that there be an accountability piece to
an adequate education um so I I I hope
that helps clarify sort of what we're
talking about with the the
accountability aspect um accountability
is a general adequacy um requirement um
you know minimum standards uh flow with
that um so I guess we Circle back around
to the argument that if if if if it's if
there's too much accountability in
public schools and too many standards
for public schools and that is somehow
inhibiting public schools from serving
all the children then let's focus on on
on where those standards are and what
the legislature can do to perhaps
eliminate some of them um but anyway
I'll wrap up my testimon I I I thank you
for indulging me uh nsba is is firmly
opposed to this bill um the language of
the statute itself uh has a lot of holes
in it and then we have the broader
policy concerns which um which we don't
think makes for a good bill either and
with that I'm happy to answer any
questions thank you very much uh ver for
your detailed presentation here uh are
you to questions happy to answer any
questions sir thank you
represent uh thank you Mr chairman thank
thank you for taking the
question opponent frequently say that
the students leave due to
the to raise property taxes that mean if
they gain students they would cut
property
taxes I I I miss part of that
representative B I just want to make
sure you said it uh opponents of voucher
bills claim that if students leave the
school property taxes will go up but if
they come back into the school property
taxes will go down was that was that the
general question General also if
students come into the school from other
reasons uh
it's lose students property taxes goes
up gain students property taxes go up
heads they win Tails they lose so case
where taxes would go down well thank you
for the question representative I I
don't know if I have a clear answer for
that but I will tell you that Manchester
has the lowest cost per pupil in the
state and I think that's because they
have the most kids um you know I'm I'm
not a a I'm not a a statistician by any
means but we know that you know a child
in and a child out um you know doesn't
change your tax rate one bit to some
degree these are economies of scale if
you have a large District such as
Manchester you can have a lower cost per
pupil conversely if you have a small
student population like say Waterville
Valley their cost per pupil is $3 or
$40,000 because you're only 10 or 15
kids that live there whatever the
numbers are so I don't know if that
answered your question but um I think
that's the best I can I can provide for
thank you rep Miler uh thank you Mr
chairman and thank you Mr Christina for
taking my question I'm referring to your
comment on page
seven uh line
four uh do you find it strange that that
in this
language that the contractors have to
comply with federal and state laws
regarding
privacy but not regarding
discrimination um thank you for the
question representative um you know that
that's also a significant concern of of
of opponents um who uh opponents of of
voucher bills in general um you know I I
I liken this to sort of uh you know a
Federal grant if you will anytime
there's a Federal Grant and I'm imagine
even a lot of state grants um if you're
accepting Federal money you have to
agree to abide by all federal you know
non-discrimination and
anti-discrimination measures um it would
you know it would be a powerful
statement from the state of New
Hampshire um I if if there were uh
enhanced or increased
anti-discrimination Provisions put
within House Bill 20 if we're going to
be you know providing these vouchers to
people to use it any way they want thank
you very much much thank you uh repres
uh thank you Mr chair thank you for
taking my question um you spoke to how
the schools are providing certain
services for free um that's in regards
to the equal access and transportation
but with that I'm a little bit confused
because I thought that that came within
the adequacy grants that come from the
state directly to the schools for those
students and I I don't quite understand
the objection to having those same
adequacy Grant funds that are going into
the EFA program paying for those exact
same services that are paid for in the
public schools with those same funds
could you help me to understand that
better please sure thank you for the
question representative I'd be I'd be
happy to um I think the most basic
answer is that adequate adequacy grants
are supposed to be paid for inadequate
education inadequate education can only
be met by following um pertinent State
statutes relative to adequacy um by
following the minimum standards from
from the Department of Education that
directly relate to State adequacy um and
all the other accountability aspects
that we talked about as well too uh to
your second question about the service
providers
um you know this again it sort of gets
back to the economy of scale a school
district May employ a speech
pathologist that Services 20 50 100 kids
in the school district um and
collectively that person is employed and
paid through some combination of both
state taxes your adequacy Grant and
local property taxes um here we're
simply giving money to parents to
provide the service that if the child
were enrolled in the public school the
child would be receiving for free anyway
you may have a special education bus
that drives three or four kids half a
dozen kids to and from school every day
whether the kids are are medically
fragile in a wheelchair whatever it may
be um so again by transporting six kids
at once
um you're saving the cost payers
taxpayers money as opposed to giving
people just a free check to transport
one child on a bus to a to a to a
potential
provider but I think the gist of the
question is that adequacy payments adade
adequacy Grant should should be used to
pay for an adequate education an
adequate education can only be met by
meeting certain state
requirements which the bill lacks it
doesn't
require um and if I may have a followup
yes follow uh my my question to this is
is the way that I read it it appears
that the students would be able to use
these grants to purchase those same
services that benefit from the economies
of scale that you just spoke to is that
something that the Schoolboard
Association is opposed to allowing them
to bring those dollars back into the
public school system for things that
that they believe are served even though
the students are served served in other
educational modes outside the system
sure thank you for the question
representative um
I don't know are so so our school
districts are now going to be vendors is
that I I mean is that what the if that
if that's the language of the bill I
understand you can bring it back in to
pro to get that speech therapy and those
OT therapy I don't think Public Schools
do that um I mean maybe a special ed
director could answer that question
better than I but it's not like it's not
like we're a private entity and we
advertise speech therapy services um and
bring kids in to receive them that
aren't residents of the district or
through some um you know uh
collaborative effort between
superintendents to share Services among
school
districts thank you and I apologize for
getting too wonky on thank very quite
all right representative thank you for
the
questions thank you Mr chair uh and
thank you Mr Christina for for um taking
my question um as you mentioned the the
scholarship fund has a lot of roles in
this bill um accountability roles um you
know auditing roles and that sort of
thing and I think most people assume
that it's going to be the child
children's scholarship fund but there's
also the giving and goinging Alliance
which is uh for Christian Schools that's
that has been approved but um kind of
flies I think a little bit under what
people know about the scholarship funds
can you see an issue if um let's say 10
different scholarship funds come into
this program and decide that they're
going to take the you know six to 10% um
is there do you see any oversight for
the scholarship
organizations in this in this bill
itself um thank you for the question
representative um I did see there was
some reporting out to the department
that the scholarship organization and Ju
Just to your first point the the giving
and going or whatever you I I'm not
familiar with that organization I hadn't
heard of them before um I mean I know
that there there is some Provisions I
think I'm on page seven where it talks
about like a legislative
oversight commission um with some
parents and whatnot um you know I I the
bulk of NHS Ba's testimony and objection
to House Bill 20 is not so much about
the organization itself but rather um
you know the manner in which we're just
getting giv money away for people to use
sort of in a manner in whichever they
manner in whatever they see
fit so I'm I I don't I guess the simple
ansers I'm sorry representative I guess
I don't have an answer for your
question thank you very
much your hand up oh yes
um thank you for taking my question you
were talking about discrimination and
saying that the schools who take the
money should follow the same
anti-discrimination laws but I'm
wondering do you think then that means
that an all girl school if they take any
girls from this they then have to take
boys as well thank you thank you for the
question representative um nobody
disputes that private entities are
allowed to create their own rules for
admission I'm not de I'm not debating
that I'm not arguing about that I'm not
making a policy decision on whether or
not an all girl school should accept
boys or whe whether or not a Christian
School should accept non-christians
that's not the point of nhp's testimony
the point is that we're giving State
money to to organizations that are
allowed to do this and we're authorizing
that in statute um that's not
necessarily the best policy or the best
practice Governor sonunu the last two
last I guess four or five years now
since he's been since he was elected in
2016 has made very concerted efforts to
ensure the safety of all students in our
public schools um expanded um workplace
protections to transgender people
expanded um uh uh school-based
protections for transgender students um
created a private right of action for
people to sue against discrim for people
to sue Public Schools against
discrimination in whatever forms that
may come so it seems peculiar to me that
while nhsb sorry while the state has
made significant efforts to combat and
address discrimination within our Public
Schools we want to turn around and say
that but other schools receiving State
adequacy money don't have to abide by
those it it it it's a little
confounding
repres thank you very thank you very
much Mr chair and thank you very much Mr
Christina for joining us this morning
and and taking my question um you had um
you had referenced um the Manchester
School District in particular saying
that uh they have the lowest cost per
pupil in the state and uh and I was
wondering does that lowest cost reflect
the uh the fair cost to educate 13,000
students um that come from the with with
really the highest um incidence of uh of
family poverty and English language
Learners uh being able to educate them
to an equitable student outcome thank
you for the question representative luno
U Mr okono chair of the Manchester Board
of school committees testified I believe
it was on the building Aid Bill uh one
of the building Aid bills and he said
that you one of their high schools is is
120 years old or something a lot about
that you know that's Statewide um we
know you know representative Vlad has
been pushing for building Aid because
Woodsville High School is however old
that is as well too so um you
know without disparaging um the
dedicated work and effort that the
administrators um School Board Wards and
most especially the parents um of the
children in Manchester are doing um the
city needs lots of help the school
district does Manchester School District
need lots of
help so followup on that Mr chair one
question no that that's fine thank you
very much Mr chair so Mr Christina would
you be interested to learn more about
Senate Bill 158 that would direct an
additional $80 million in state funding
to the Manchester School District um I'd
be very interested in learning about
that b I'll pull it up as soon as I my
testimony can concludes thank you just
it just received the bill number
yesterday gotcha thank you thank you
very much what I'm GNA do right now is
not take any more questions I don't
believe we are have that many more
questions from the committee uh I think
we've done a good job in questioning the
two speakers which we just had the
presenters one from one side of the
point the from the other side going very
thorough and hopefully this will assist
people that are coming up to testify in
the future that they can Echo maybe the
thoughts of one or the other and and say
that so that we don't have to do a lot
of repeating today uh so with that I
would like to go on and I'm going to set
now we haven't had a Time Lim for these
first two speakers was pretty much even
as far as time between the two of them
so we're going to now go to the time
limit and it's going to be two minutes
uh per testifier from this point forward
we're still with well over 140 people
wanting to testify today that's divide
that by 2 minutes per person add a
little bit on in between time and we we
have really got some hours in front of
us here so with that I'd like to call
repr hson to get the next person in L
and we will start tracking with time
thank you okay so the next person who's
going to speak is representative Linda
Linda okay okay next next speaker who
I'm going to promote is representative
Leah Leah
pushman Leah I hope you're there I just
lost you
somewhere there you
[Music]
please hi can you hear
me hold on a second Leah I'm sorry for
the confusion rep F got herself
unmuted
okay so who do we have up on Deck here
Leah kushman go ahead oh thank you um
thank you Mr chairman thank you uh
members of of the committee um my name
is Leah representative Leah kushman I
represent wear and Dearing in Hillsboro
County District 2 um I'm testifying
today go ahead unmuted her I'm trying to
find out just a reminder to all those
that testifying if you have written
testimony please submit that to the
clerk and summarize your your testimony
go ahead
represent thank you so my eldest son was
in public school until age seven he had
an IEP he received a lot of extra help
um despite the special reading time he
got with the special needs professionals
um every day he still had great
difficulty learning to read for my son a
boy with a uh a boy with attention
deficit and hyperactivity disorder to
have to sit in his seat for six hours
each day wasn't working for him he
didn't like learning at that point and
resisted um any kind of teaching uh in
school and at home and he viewed all of
it as just awful work that he didn't
want to do um at that time I decided to
take my son out of public school and we
began
homeschooling uh for six months we did
what's known as deschooling which is
where you don't do any formal schooling
but instead fill your days with Museum
visits Library trips exploring nature
reading together and just talking about
what interests the child the idea is
you're following the child's lead and
exploring his interests discussing his
ideas and thoughts and answering
questions in a laid laid-back way to let
him learn to enjoy learning
again um by the end of that six months
my son who had been um unable to read
became a fluent reader um very quickly
with the freedom to direct his education
toward his interests in a flexible
manner that worked for him is what uh
made that possible the local public
schools may not offer what individual
students need they set standards which
the teachers have to teach to and
students who fall within a window of
those standards not too advanced and not
too far behind do very well well for
other students who may have different
learning styles it may not work out so
well and they need something different
we pay thousands of dollars in property
taxes every year around 80% of which
goes to our local school dist School
District in my town for the purpose of
educating children so many families
could benefit from using alternative
education method methods whether it be a
different public school private school
homeschool or Charter School I believe
if people truly care about children then
they would support this
legislation if these people who um claim
they care about children being
discriminated against don't support this
legislation you have gone beyond two
minutes so we're going have that
conclude with a single sentence and we
will move to the next speaker okay the
next speaker I'm are we not are we not
taking questions y well I want her to
conclude and then the next next person
might want to ask a question go ahead
what I want I I'm giving represent an
opportunity to give her summary
statement thank
you uh my summary is just that children
learn in different ways and this
provides an opportunity for us to give
an adequate education to kids in a way
that they need it and there's no
discrimination because you're sending
your you have a choice of where to send
your kids so we this discrimination
isn't an issue either thank thank you
very much representative kushman are
questions for representative yes
represent thank you very much Mr chair
um and thank you very much
representative kushman for uh for
joining us this morning and being
willing to uh to take a question you had
mentioned um during your testimony that
um that people in wear um uh spend pay
thousands of dollars a year in um in
local property taxes to uh to support
your public schools and I was wondering
if you would be interested in learning
more about Senate Bill 158 which would
actually um hold funding you know the
same in um in wear but would actually
reduce property taxes in wear by
$484 per
thousand sure I'd be interested in in
learning about it absolutely great thank
you
question not any questions the next
speaker is Deborah uh representative
Deborah Al
I'm sorry I am not signed up to speak
but I thank you for the opportunity I'm
I'm just here listening I've already
signed in okay thank very much thank you
very much
representative the next person the next
person is representative Stapleton and
the uh I don't see him signed up any
longer so I will go
to can I ask a question while we're
waiting sure yes go ahead I I may have
missed this chairman did you announce at
the beginning how many have signed in
for or against or are we going to get
that information by the end of the day
or at the end of the
meeting I'm sorry it comes at the end of
the hearing I will give that information
I don't see the next couple of speakers
I'm going off the old list uh from last
minute
Baker okay uh I'm going to unmute um
Deanna
jurius um
Mi Mr chair okay yes yeah um just a a
point of inquiry a point point of
information um I I think I see the um
mayor
danes's and um seeing that he's an
elected official in the state's second
largest city um not sure if if you
wanted to uh catch his time while he's
available right now and I will get Mayor
following terrific thank you thank you
representative
now okay go ahead Diana oh good
morning all right thank you Mr chairman
and members of the committee uh my name
is D jurus and I'm representing the
Josiah barlot Center for Public Policy
uh for the record I served representing
bellnap District 2 in the house in the
last
bium um I'm not taking a position today
on hb20 but I'm here to provide
information about education savings
accounts um to begin I'd like to take a
step back and look at the big picture
every participant in this believes that
education is essential to the Future
well-being of our children and our state
and ongoing conversations about
education funding are a big piece of
that however I'd like to put that aside
for a minute and talk about children how
great are children they're naturally
curious they're Avid Learners they're
very active and brigh eyed um there's
just something about being with a child
that Sparks life in a person and each
child is unique and it's one of the joys
of life to watch them grow up and
develop their own personalities um
that's what we're really talking about
here we're talking about children and
how to serve each student with the best
education for their unique abilities and
personalities and education savings
accounts are a proven way of doing
this currently adequate education grants
for each student are given directly to
the school district or Charter School
child attends that can leave children in
educational settings that aren't a good
fit for them we are currently funding
schools but not necessarily the best
education for each child in those
schools with an Esa program the state
would deposit that child's education
grant into a government approved savings
account so that amilies can pay for
state approved educational expenses
finally letting families match their
child to the education that best suits
him or her they're not a new public
policy idea nor are they destroying
Public Schools five states currently
have Esa programs Arizona Florida
Mississippi Tennessee and North Carolina
and as mentioned last week Arizona's
program started in 2011 and right now
about 4% of eligible students are
participating in the program school
choice programs including esas have
shown by numerous academic studies to
improve student outcome
in 17 studies of academic achievement 11
found gains in achievement four found no
effect and only three found a decline in
test
scores we're at the uh end of your two
minutes uh can you please wrap that up
and
questions certainly um so by letting
families match their children with the
education that best suits them esas
improve academic performance for both
participating and non-participating
students and make families more
satisfied with the education their
children are getting thanks very much uh
other questions for
Diana
Josiah not seeing any questions from me
thank you very much thank you okay next
week um National mayor Mr
dones the next person we're gonna call
n
remind please have
testimony oh sorry you have written
testimony from all those who have been
testifying please submit that to our
cler represent sha so she won't have to
keep writing in everything that you're
saying it really does process side thank
you go ahead May uh thank you Mr chair
for recognizing me um I wanted to
address a couple of points points the
first being the idea that when a child
leaves the public schools to go to a
private school of some kind that that
saves the school district money that is
not usually the case in fact uh usually
nothing is saved and and I can explain
why I'm going to use Nash as an example
not because it's different or more
important or anything but just because I
know the numbers but this is true in
every Community large and small so we
have 4 some
classrooms across 17 schools and 12
grades plus kindergarten plus a little
bit of
prek so let's say 300 kids
leave now so there's one kid in Amis
Street school at in the third grade you
know two kids uh in a couple of
different grades in another school the
class size gets reduced from 21 to 20 or
something like that it doesn't save any
money at
all Because unless the people leaving
were concentrated all in one classroom
or all in one
grade which never is going to happen you
still have the same teaching
infrastructure you same have still have
the same schools all of the same
expenses so maybe over very very long
term you know if a if many kids left
over many years I mean yeah eventually
there might be some savings but
certainly in the short term there
absolutely
nothing uh number two I would just like
to address the uh cost of an adequate
education now there's a constitutional
mandate that the state provide funding
for an adequate education the fiscal
note on the bill says that the cost is
average State average is 19,000 or
something approaching that and the
adequacy grant is 3600 so the state is
not even coming close to to meeting its
obligation to fund an adequate education
and if there are educational funds
available uh the you know and those
should go in my opinion to the public
schools until we really do fund an
adequate
education the third the cost of the kids
that are already out of of not even in
public schools where there would be
clearly no savings the commissioner
testified the other day that all those
children would be eligible for the uh
the adequacy grant kids that are already
in private schools well if you look at
the fiscal note you see that there are
22,000 kids between private schools and
homeschooling who would receive or be
eligible to receive these funds these
State
funds
um Mr Mayor uh we we are at end your
please he has to unmute have to unmute
un so 50 or hundred million doll will go
out of the state you know uh just for
kids that are already in private school
in any event thank you Mr chair for the
opportunity to testify Mr are you
willing to take questions yeah of course
thank you very much repres thank you Mr
chair thank you Mr Mayor uh May n you
You' really testified to this committee
about your concerns about Nash losing
students and revenue to Innovation
schools do you still have that
concern I've never said that I don't
know when what you're talking about but
um I have not testified that I'm worried
about losing kids to Innovation schools
what I'm worried about is that the state
is not
providing nearly enough assistance to
provide an adequate education and when
someone does leave to go to another
school it does not result in savings to
the school
district thank thank you very much Mr
Mayor uh representative luno and
then thank you very much Mr chair and
and thanks thanks very much Mr Mayor for
joining us this morning and and being
willing to uh to to take uh take
questions um I was wondering if um if uh
you would be interested in in learning
more about um uh Senate Bill 158 which
would actually reduce uh property taxes
in um in the city of nashaa by 78 cents
but it would also direct uh nearly $224
million of additional State educational
grants to them um uh to the nashwa
school district and that amounts
calculated specifically to improve uh
the student outcomes that you were
talking about order Mr chair is this
appropriate for him to keep asking about
a separate bill asking the same question
everybody regarding no no there I'm not
question so and and it's directed to the
mayor's um comments about student
outcomes okay go
[Music]
ahead no no I've I've asked the question
or you have a question rep yeah I I
asked the question all right can you
hear me now I don't know um if I'm
allowed to answer the question I would
say yes I'd be more interested in
learning about it but I'm concerned
about educational quality in public
schools across the state of New
Hampshire cities like man NASA but also
small towns where you know kids there
deserve just the same help so uh I'm
concerned about Nashville but really all
kids in the state thank you Mr
Mayor further questions I thank you Mr
chair and thank you Mr Mayor since this
loss of State funds and property taxes
tax increases is such a concern what is
your plan to deal with the declining
enrollment numbers that we've been
seeing over the past decades and our
forecasted to continue without property
tax
increases uh well if you look at uh the
percentages that departments in
Nashville have gone up the school
department has gone up significantly
less than the police department the fire
department Public Works and other
departments and I think that's
because uh the you know gradually the
declining enrollment which is not
terribly significant I but we still have
over 11,000 kids uh the uh the declining
enrollment probably over a period of
very long period of time has enabled the
district to keep costs down below what
other departments have going
up thank you are there any further
questions for the
mayor not seeing any hands thank you
very much Mr Mayor thank you for the
opportunity you're welcome the next
speaker is Melody McDonald and she's
been
promoted thank you very much I
appreciate the opportunity to speak with
you all today um first class wallet uh
is a financial technology uh this year
we are um under contract and currently
in the process of Contracting to work
with about $550 million of federal uh
Grant funds uh with state and local
agencies being delivered to both
families for programs like this in Esa
teachers and schools uh we did help
Arizona to resolve their challenges with
uh fraud and do completely eliminate the
possibility of fraud as a financial
technology what we do is provide a
closed loop system where families uh
could only access first of all vendors
that have been preapproved and vetted by
the granting organization and not be
able to pay anyone outside of that
boundary um additionally um as an
education wallet um parents access that
pool of approved only vendors they uh
they then can submit a digital um
request very very easy for parents to
use by the way um and and that digital
request actually for the specific either
uh Service uh like a tutor for example
or educational item that they need get
submitted but it actually doesn't go
anywhere they're simply making a a
request uh once the request is made that
goes over to the granting administrator
that Grant administrator has full
opportunity to vet and make sure that
that is fully compliant with the B
within the boundaries of where the money
can be spent so it completely eliminates
the pro possibility of fraud as no
purchase can happen unless it's approved
once that is approved we facilitate the
payment and the money flow of that
transaction in other words we will pay
the vendor we will they will be able to
get the goods through one of our vendors
in the marketplace that they have been
allowed to access we deal with shipping
process the payment process the
invoicing process for all
vendors thank you you're you're beyond
your two minutes now could you please
wrap it up and then we'll yes sir yes
sir um we also provide detailed
reporting that is completely accessible
um to the grant administrator and um and
you know keeps everything so that it is
full fully
transparent than much are you willing to
take questions yes I'm I'm glad to take
questions
repres uh thank you Mr chairman and and
thank you Miss McDonald for being with
us today could you tell the committee
please what is uh your administrative
fee for conducting this service
absolutely our administrative fee is
0.5% um and then as far as the rest goes
the vendors in the marketplace pay us a
um you know a commissionable amount uh
we also have a transaction fee that is
um you know not doesn't need to be paid
by the state uh just very similar if you
could imagine PayPal and how when
someone swipes a card there's a
transaction fee um when someone pays
with PayPal we have that as well and
that payment can be directed to wherever
you would like that most times and in
the case of Arizona for example that
payment is directed to the vendors just
like when somebody pays their babysitter
with the PayPal there's a fee that comes
out and that's
2.5% thank you thank you very much uh
representa thank you Mr chair uh and
thank you for your testimony could you
possibly send the committee uh a a good
description of your system and process I
have a h three minute overview video
would that suffice that would be great
if you could uh send it to us absolutely
thank you
representan oh thank you for taking my
question thank you Mr chair thank you
for taking my question um I had a
question about for example if I wanted
to purchase a a novel um from Kindle
books on
Amazon and um would
Amazon then be one of the um granting
vendors or would I have to go to a
vendor for the same book that may be of
a high higher price that that has been
approved good question so um we will
allow whatever vendors um your your team
the granting administrator wants to
allow so Amazon can be allowed in the
marketplace or not allowed in the
marketplace um and uh and there are uh
around 60 uh educational vendors and we
can also onboard local vendors such as a
local tutor if that is permissible um so
we don't really arbitrate you know
whether or not a vendor uh is allowed or
not that's for you to decide from The
Wheelhouse of what is acceptable um and
there should be plenty of opportunity to
shop that novel around um and if it's
not a permissible novel then that data
of the name and the title of the book
The Novel itself will go over to the
grant administrator and they'll be able
to look at that and say am I going to
allow this novel or
not um a followup then on that please Mr
chair yes go ahead so so um what are you
saying that the grant
administrator actually can choose to not
allow them to take a certain novel or a
certain
textbook yes that that's not something
that we arbitrate they have the the
grant administrator can look at the
compliancy guidelines and decide whether
that novel is compliant and either
approve or reject the
purchase thank you very much I don't see
any other
questions MERS thank you very
much thank you appreciate your time and
the opportunity I will follow up with
that video and some other information
thank you very much
Kelly I'm sorry I'm looking for Shana
Kelly um she had signed up to speak last
week as an elected official but she's
she's not here
Hilt I don't see her either
sorry
huh
the the old many old people are not here
today uh so we they jump to the new list
and try to work through that and then
to
see
okay okay so um that clears up the
elected officials the next
person is Al Britney there again for all
those that are to offer testimony I
please request you to not read your
testimony if you have't written please
submit it to cler and then try to
summarize okay we'll have a two
minute time okay uh next speaker is
andry
Banfield youve you not on this subject
Anar you've been
promoted go ahead okay thank you very
much um my name is Anar Banfield and I'm
an advocate for parental rights and
academic excellence and education I do
come here in support of hb20 however I
do have some concerns with the language
and want to make sure that it would
protect the homeschool Community I think
others may be testifying on that so I'm
just going to kind of skip over that
part um we heard about accountability I
again want to stress that this bill
allows accountability to parents and
when I work with parents across the
state is because they feel that there's
no accountability in their Viewpoint
which is what brings them to me in the
first place so you know we can go back
and forth with accountability but you
know there's a lot of parents out there
that uh don't feel like their school
what that they're in uh is accountable
to them um most of what I approached you
with on uh HB 607 I I would duplicate on
this bill in terms of using a balanced
approach supporting public excellence in
public education and choice for the few
who need it uh in my research parents
prefer their local public school there's
no doubt about it when you provide uh an
excellent uh education choice in the
public schools that's where parents want
their kids most parents superintendant
have school choice they can choose
private or religious schools and divert
public funds towards those schools they
send some of their children to religious
or private schools that have their own
policies in terms of who they will
accept no one has brought forth any
issues of discrimination when they
choose a school to send some of their
public school students too so in terms
of the schools that accept these
students or in the fact that public
schools will not do all that they can do
to provide the best education for their
CH for that child so using the kind of
logic that we've heard today in terms of
discrimination it it almost seems like
you can make a case then that the public
school is discriminating against the
child that they're sending to a private
school because they can't provide the
needs for that specific child I think we
need to just go back to
letting Miss bfield we are now beyond
the two minutes so can you please
uh Mar I don't and Marie I don't think
I'm sorry sure you know just to to to
bring up one last point is that schools
also divert public funds to lobbying
organizations like the nhba the nhsaa Lo
local taxpayers pay their salaries and
then we hear them talk about how this
would divert funds to private schools
but this is happening
in public schools as we speak so I just
think that those are the kinds of those
are the kinds of things we need to think
about you know we're arguing back and
forth where this money is being diverted
to but we need to make sure that we're
we're we're diverting it for the best
interest of the child and I think that's
what hb20 does so thank you for taking
my
testimony Mr Mr chair Mr chair can I ask
that people people be given some sort of
warning when they're close to the two
minutes I find it
very almost rude that uh people are
getting um muted uh right mids sentence
I mean at least give them some sort of
warning that they're uh maybe within 30
seconds of their two minutes so they can
wrap it up and and um I think that that
would work much better respon to your
request represent we do have
seconds however people are M I don't
want to off that point time and they
keep for for for us to interject right
here using a technology we have
still was we had mute them then we try
to explain but it's given
it's due to the nature of this
technology we can't stop at end of they
go right into the next so we're trying
to work with all that this we have this
why I have an individual here the sign
down so where we are right
now
questions yeah are there any questions
not seeing any hands up thank you very
um okay next speaker we're going to
promote is Jim
oon go ahead Mr oconnell welcome to
education
you're G to have okay sorry sorry I was
muted I apologize can you hear me now
yes okay thank you uh thank you chairman
thank you committee members for the
opportunity to speak today uh in
recognition of all the speakers yet to
come and those gone I I'll I'll be very
brief um first of all I just want to
correct something earlier today at this
hearing it was said that I was the vice
chair of the
the school board Committee in Manchester
I'm actually a school board Committee
Member from Manchester I'm a Committee
Member at large representing all 12
Wards but I am not the current Vice
chair I am the chair of the education
legislation Committee of the manest
school board um but I'm here today
speaking on on my own behalf as a school
board member in Manchester so um just
very briefly uh first of all I'd
identify with the remarks of bar
Christina earlier and I'd refer the
committee to a submission saying by
Bishop Robert hershfield the Episcopal
Bish Bishop of of New Hampshire
yesterday I think it's an important
Viewpoint that represents it represents
of churchgoing people in in the state of
New Hampshire that correctly identifies
the division between church and state
and the inequity of um of uh uh involved
in in using public funds uh for those
purposes I one one other thing I would
say is that with regard to Manchester
and the and the efficiencies of of of
larger populations um the Reas the
numbers for per student spending in the
state of New Hampshire have just been
released for last year in Manchester is
actually it's third from the bottom
there are two smaller towns that spend
slightly less but they only have
elementary schools but we're spending
122,000 dollar 1225 thousand per student
the state average is close to 20 um if
people want to rest easy in bed at night
time by telling themselves that that's
because of efficiencies of numbers then
so be it but that's being delusional the
fact is we have uh huge deficiencies
that that uh that that we're coping with
we're looking at a h large budget
reduction in Manchester reducing
services and doing everything we can to
provide an an education to the many
children in our great City and um it
makes no sense to me to be honest when I
in we Jim we you know at the end of that
few minutes could you please summarize
where you are and then we'll open up to
questions thank you chairman yes I I I
I'll just summarize by what I I refer to
to the to the to the the people I refer
to um I I I just I just think that there
is such a lack of of funding already in
in in public education in the state to
uh to divert money from that desperate
need is H is just doesn't make good
economic sense for the State of New
questions uh Mr luno I'm sorry rep luno
has his hand
rais thank you very much Mr chair and
thank you very much um um Mr oconnell
for uh for joining us um this morning
and and talking about Manchester
do you believe that um and this is
specific to your testimony do you
believe that um that the Manchester
school district is um is funded I guess
appropriately that would provide the
opportunity for an adequate education or
at least a Statewide um um adequate
outcome for students yeah I I think that
think thank you for the question
representative luno I I think that you
know we we we can be dispassionate and
objective and just look at data and
numbers and and you know there are
judgments we can make on some things but
just in terms of data I talked to here
last week we talk about the this
building funding issue about the average
school in Manchester being 70 years old
uh we're closing a school we just
announced it last week um so we go from
22 schools to 21 um but in in data terms
we have uh the largest or some of the
large some we've improved a little in
the last a couple of years but we've got
some of the largest class sizes in the
state in terms of per pupil rate r
we uh we pay uh when I look at I looked
at the number $80 million uh that might
go through that might go from this
funding just if people in P private
schools presy were to go if you consider
we pay a starting teacher 39,000 that's
rough that's as near to 40 as you can
get divide 40,000 into 80 million that's
we could hire 2,000 starting teachers
for the amount of money that this bill
might send elsewhere so I won't go on
but the data is very clear um we do not
we are not in a position to give the
children of Manchester the education
that they
deserve follow up on that Mr
chair yeah thank thank you so uh would
the with the 80 million that would be um
directed to Manchester through Center
Bill 158 um uh move Manchester closer to
um to uh uh you know Statewide um um uh
performance outcomes uh without writing
the paper on that I would of course I
would just point this out that under the
the numbers from last year I I haven't
done the calculation for this year but
numbers from last year Manchester spends
$53 million less than what it would
spend if it spent the state average per
student so if we just spend and clearly
we have not just the average level of
need in the city of Manchester we've
greater than the average uh level of
need but if we were to just spend the
state average that what every other town
in the state spends on their students
per student if we just did that we would
need an additional $53 million and just
to make the point clearly the tax the
property taxpayers of Manchester we
could never Levy $53 million and expect
the the working people of Manchester and
the home owners to pay that great thank
you very
much see any other questions for General
thank you very much Jim thank you sir I
appreciate
itus uh we have uh Mr Jonathan
Weinberg hi um thank you I'll try to
make this pretty brief my name is
Jonathan Weber and I'm a recently
elected member of the conquered school
board and a product of the New Hampshire
Public School System last week the
conquered School Board issued a Stern
statement opposing this legislation
statement is as follows our district is
dedicated to cultivating and providing a
strong and inclusive public education
for students in our schools House Bill
20 also known as the Richard Dick hinch
education freedom savings account
program compromises not only this ideal
but our public education system as a
whole therefore we the conquered School
Board unequivocally stand a post hp20
and any iteration that seeks to
dismantle our public education system I
would just like to note that entities
like police agencies and firefighters
are not becoming privatized as we
instead allocate additional public funds
to support these agencies so why are we
attempting to privatize our public
education system this does not make
education more accessible or even lower
educational costs but merely places more
burden on local school districts to
supplement the loss income from State
adequacy funding I thank you for your
time and I'm open to questions but I
know there is a long
list thank you questions from committee
members repr luno yeah thank you very
much Mr chair and and thank you very
much um Mr Weinberg for joining us this
morning and for your work with the uh
with the conquered School Board would
would you say that um property taxpayers
in conquered are working pretty hard
to um U to provide the um the the the
level of funding that you do in
conquered for um to educate conquered
students I think definitely especially
as we're in budget season right now uh
the onus is definitely on the property
taxpayers to ensure that we provide an
adequate education so follow up on that
yes thank thank you very much Mr chair
would you be interested in learning more
about Senate Bill 158 that would would
reduce that could reduce the property
tax rate and conquered by over $2 per
thousand and still provide the same I'm
sorry I'm
soror representative but we're talking
about20 not Senate bills
today okay
questions next speaker is next speaker
is um Chris Ager Chris you've been
promoted uh go ahead and
speak good morning my name is uh Chris
Ager I'm representing myself I live in
Amherst uh New Hampshire I'm a former
School Board member of a neighboring
town I support
hb20 I support it on conceptual grounds
that first our first mission should be
what's best for the children what's the
best way we can educate them I believe
the one thing we're missing in education
now is vigorous competition comp
competition Spurs Innovation it can help
lower cost and it can increase the
responsiveness of the organization to
the
consumer um so I'm I know that perfect
is the enemy of good enough but hb20 is
a great step towards competition and
doing what's best for the students and
the children I urge you to support hb20
thank you very
much thank you Mr AER U questions from
rep Tanner uh represent
Tanner uh thank you uh Mr chair and
thank you for taking my question Mr
Agger
um I was a longtime coach uh at the high
school that I taught at and one thing
about competition is that you kind of
need a fair playing playing field do you
consider um public schools that have to
accept every student um regardless of
their ability or their income or um any
any kind of attribute that that puts
them on a fair playing field with a
private school that can pick and choose
who they um take as their
students sure thank you for the question
so bringing everybody down to the worst
possible lowest comedy denominator I
think is the absolute worst possible
public policy you can you can have we
should have the a a chain as strong as
the strongest link let every child
achieve their potential don't bring them
down because someone else cannot achieve
so we should absolutely do the best for
individual children one at a time cookie
cutter does not work in business I don't
think it works well in
education just think if we forced
everyone to go to McDonald's we'd get
greasy burgers limpy fries and watery
milkshakes but we have competition it
drives them to provide better for all of
their consumers and it actually drives a
price down we wouldn't have Chick-fil-A
or Wendy's if we treated fast food the
education thank you Mr chairman Mr a
thank you just for taking my question I
um I find it uh distressing that you're
uh comparing widgets and business and
and uh projects and production to
students um I'm just trying to figure
parallel so it's in in running an
organization and getting
efficiency why would you not learn from
best practices in business keeping in
mind that the number one mission is
those individual
students it's and if you can do it
better within the same budget or even
pay more to get a better quality product
why wouldn't you try to do that why
wouldn't you allow people to go to find
what's best for them it's like water
flowing down a hill it'll find the right
path to meet what they need and so to
force everyone especially people who
don't have the money and the financial
resources to force them to go to a
school that may not work for them I
don't think is looking out for the best
interest of the students follow up Mr
chairman if I
may yes thank you just one final on your
your analogy Mr M Mike if you do you
believe if you take 800 millionar are
the public school system that's going to
make it
better yes I absolutely do necessity is
the mother of invention we took
consumers out of
McDonald's by allowing Wendy's and
Chick-fil-A McDonald's didn't go away
they didn't go out of business they
didn't get worse they got better they
Rose to the challenge of the competition
the individual The Innovation from
Individual teachers superintendent
school districts will drive a better
environment for everyone competition
breeds Innovation and Innovation is
Paramount to public education thank you
Mr chairman represent luno thank you
very much Mr chairman and thank you very
much Mr Ager for being with us this
morning and for taking um my question
but um uh we've had testimony here by
from the commission
um that uh about New Hampshire's public
school student outcomes being you know
top five you know in the country so I
was just sort of wondering what you are
talking about when you when you refer to
the lowest common
denominator so I was responding thank
you for the question I was responding to
the uh to the the the previous um
legislator's question uh with respect to
to widgets versus versus students um but
number five is good but every single
individual child is not in the top five%
or the top five and so why not allow
them to do the best that they can do as
an individual student and why not allow
that it just seems to me we would
absolutely want every individual student
to find the best path for them and if we
can help by allowing them and helping
them to go somewhere else at a much
lower average cost than what we we need
to spend for our public students why
wouldn't we do that and have everyone do
better we can always do better everyone
can do
better follow up on that Mr chair so
when you refer to the a much lower
average cost what are you what are you
referring to there I'm talking about the
C the average cost per student versus
what the allocation would be for student
20 okay thank you I mean thank
you thank you Mr Ager thank you next
speaker is uh Bonnie Bonnie Dunham and
she's been promoted so go ahead and
unmute
yourself there Hi I believe I'm unmuted
now Bonnie Dunham from Marram New
Hampshire and I agree with the points
that have been raised by others who
oppose
hb20 I really fear that communities
school districts and children remaining
in public schools will pay dearly for
hb20 and I have three main reasons for
opposing this bill one is fiscal and in
addition to everything you've heard hb20
does not require a parent to withdraw a
child from public school and so a child
who only becomes ineligible for an EFA
if they attend a public school for more
than half the time could conceivably
attend a public school for 49% of the
day receiving any accommodations they
need such as an interpreter maybe even
special education at the expense of the
public school that has receiving no
funds parent could also use an EFA to
pay for an intensive short-term therapy
or en or enrichment program and then
reenroll their child in the public
school for the rest of the year again no
state aid available and even if a child
reenroll full-time the EFA St funds
still stay available for the parent to
use while the public school is educating
their child New Hampshire is
experiencing unprecedented challenges is
this really the best time to establish a
costly program that some people want but
don't need um it lacks accountability
doesn't include any performance
accountability measures only an annual
satisfaction survey doesn't require
qualifications for providers as you've
heard not even a criminal background
check while I know it's not the intent
with unqualified providers able to teach
children with no follow-up
accountability I fear that for some
children hb20 may become the freedom
from Education Act it supports
discrimination it's very clear they
can't discriminate against providers
it's a different story about children
children can be discriminated against
including on the basis of disability and
since the Ada the Americans with
Disabilities Act is exempt from the from
um the Ada any any private religious
school could openly and explicitly
discriminate against a child based on
that child's disability I've included
the citation in my written testimony it
claims to expand opportunities for
children but by allowing this type of
discrimination it actually reduces
opportunities for the most vulnerable
groups of children I really do not want
to pay taxes to support private schools
that can discriminate against my child
so please don't pass this bill an
earlier
minutes and then we open up questions
take
M Mr chair can I ask a question um if
the if these people are calling in uh do
they see Representatives Leon's little
uh
marker that that's why I'm also having
to you know cut in and and let them know
that they've gone beyond I'm trying to
be courteous and allow them to go beyond
a little bit and and
summarize but yes and and I realize that
and and that's what I'm asking but it
seems like they're being muted mids
sentence which to me is rude I think
that if you cut in at the end of a
sentence when it's appropriate it would
be much better I I just I I'm having
problems with this um
process I had one sentence
left best we can repres hson has to you
know do the technology stuff over there
after I give her the signal that we've
gone beyond and so we're trying to time
it properly but yes it does sometimes
come in the middle of the sentence and
and I I don't know how to fix that um
it's the nature of having remote
testimony
disrespectful so is
is still there yep she is she's
unmuted I had one sentence left I was
halfway through my last sentence if I
could finish so saying that there's no
discrimination because people can choose
where to send their schools it's like
saying whites only lunch counters were
not discriminatory because people could
choose to eat someplace
else thank you very much Bonnie and
welcome it's good to hear your voice
again here at the education committee
absolutely yes I was
um I was wondering if you knew that
in here one of the um possible ex um
expenses is for Public School courses so
that if a kid did go 49% of the time to
the high school the high school would
have to be paid out of that educational
Freedom account I did read that it
wasn't clear though and since um RSA 193
allows children who are homeschooled or
attending private schools to participate
in extracurricular and co-curricular
activities at their Public School it it
doesn't say that they have to pay for it
followups yes you may um the educ the uh
doe does pay the state does pay for
those um when a homeschooler goes to a
high school a that's pro-rated and that
is paid for by the state
if a child needs an interpreter the
state does not pay for
that while they're attending that
example thank you very much M are there
further
questions Mullen has her hand
up
mull you there thank you uh thank you Mr
chair and thank you uh Miss Dunham for
taking the question um Miss Dunham am I
correct that you um in your professional
capacity serve as an advocate for
parents who have special needs children
yes I'm here as a private citizen but I
work at the parent information center
where I provide Education and Training
for parents so that they can participate
meaningfully and making decisions for
their child in the special ed
process okay so I a followup please uh
Mr chair um so I would I would not I I
know that you can't answer this question
with any kind of 100 % accuracy but is
is it your opinion that if parents were
given funds and able to go out and
choose their own provider for
services uh that they would have
difficulty
navigating how and who to
choose yes I I believe that that would
be difficult and particularly to ensure
that all of their child's needs were met
um it's a really emotional decision that
people make and um and sometimes things
fall through the cracks and then the
public school will pick up the pieces
after the child
welcome see has his hand
up thank you re thank you for taking my
question Miss Dunham in this bill I
believe that if a parent should choose
to uh participate in this voucher
program that has a uh special ed student
they give up any of their rights uh both
Statewide and federally for any
assistance uh once they accept this
voucher if that is
true uh what might be some of the
problems that a parent would incur as a
result of making that
choice first it doesn't say that it says
that the scholarship organization would
inform that theyve that they have lost
rights but it doesn't say that they do
um and so that's a that's not quite
clear and then if a if a parent places a
child privately um and it's a nonprofit
private school the school district where
that child is where that school is
located still has some responsibility to
to serve that child minimal
responsibility but some and so I think
parents would have a hard time um
grasping that concept completely about
what they really are giving up and then
finding a way to make up for that using
private funds those services are way
more expensive than I think some people
understand thank you you're
welcome
questions not see any hands thank you
very
much you're welcome thank you thank you
Miss Dunham next
we okay next we have Karen Lloyd Hill
you've been promoted so you can unmute
go
ahead hello thank you so much my name is
Karen Leo Hill I'm a 16 Senor City
councelor in the city of Lebanon I am
here today in opposition to hb20 I was
actually homeschooled for high school
myself uh so I think I have a an
interesting perspective on this my two
daughters went to Lebanon Public Schools
um where they have had um good
experiences it seems to me that some of
the underlying motivation for this bill
is to improve public education in New
Hampshire and I think that's actually
something that many of us agree on
there's common ground on a lot of this
but in fact if the motivation is to
improve public education then removing
funding from the public schools is not
the way to achieve this we should be
looking at how to actually address the
inadequacies in our public schools and
make those improvements I want to
underscore two particular points because
I don't want to repeat what others have
said last week I heard commissioner edel
blute speak about the three-year um the
I think he called it a a generous
three-year window before schools would
start losing funding based on declining
enrollment due to these efas well in
fact schools are built uh the
Investments for infrastructure um
usually require bonds that are over many
decades and those fixed costs are spread
out over um over many decades and
there's this concept of
intergenerational Equity where all of us
are contributing to the costs associated
with providing public education a
threeyear window um before schools start
losing funds is not going to address the
long-term Investments and debt that
schools have had to take on in order to
provide those facilities I know how
precious taxpayer dollars are as a local
official and I know how devastating it
will be as property taxes continue to
rise due to this uh due to
hb20 I also want to talk about the
impact on vulnerable children we have
been facing uh most parents of course
are going to make good choices for their
children and would certainly use funds
to improve uh to improve the situation
children thank you I'll can I just
wrap
I'll just wrap by saying that as
lawmakers we also have to consider the
most vulnerable and what will happen
when some parents don't make the best
choices and use the funds for other
purposes I encourage you all to um think
about the most vulnerable in our
communities as you are taking a position
please um thank you for taking my
question
um I was wondering if you could maybe
tell us how you feel the public school
system uh is a kind of a safety net for
vulnerable children in your
area thank you so much representative
Tanner I think that when children are in
schools and there's been concern about
this over this past year with remote
learning when children are in schools
there is in in fact Ed a great safety
net around them there are people who can
notice um what might be going on in
someone's life there might be people who
notice bruising uh that might not that
that shouldn't be there there are people
who notice uh we know that um school
that food scarcity is a real problem in
New Hampshire and there are people in
schools who this is schools are a source
of food for a lot of students in New
Hampshire and there are people the
teachers the Paras the school nurse uh
there's just a whole community of people
of other adults who are looking who are
looking out for people and you know I
think we know in New Hampshire from the
over the last several years the
testimony about child protective
services and
DCF that there are children who are
vulnerable and who are being exploited
and I think that is a serious concern
for this committee to think about um
you okay thank you
um and uh next we'll welcome in Mary
wilky Mary wilky uh you're you've been
promoted go ahead and speak please hi
thank you can you hear me yes thank you
thank you very much for taking my
testimony I'm Mary wilky from conquered
and I oppose this bill and I'll just
make two quick points that I haven't
heard made before um one is that the
Bill's supporters say there's nothing
unconstitutional about sending public
money to religious schools and uh even
if that's true that doesn't make it good
public policy um textbooks used in some
of our the religious schools in New
Hampshire um say for instance that
Catholics are practicing distorted
Christianity I don't think taxpayers who
are uh Catholic should be required to
pay for books that denounce their
religion and nor do I want to pay for
books that teach children that men
should dominate women secondly
supporters justify esas by saying
they're for children who just aren't
getting what they need in public school
but if that's the case I wonder why the
program is open even to children who
have never stepped foot in a public
school uh last year I heard a parent
testify in in um support of the
education tax credit scholarship program
which uses the same justification she
said that as soon as she learned about
that program she signed up all eight of
her children and sent them to private
school and it's hard for me to believe
that not a single one of those eight
children could have gotten what they
need in public
school I believe that the best way to
help students who aren't getting what
they need in their local school would be
to focus on the thousands of students
who live in property poor towns who are
denied opportunities that their peers in
wealthier towns have a child whose
school doesn't offer chemistry foreign
language elos or the Arts is also not
getting what she needs these systemic in
Equity should be addressed before we
create a whole new parallel system of
publicly funded private schools the
state just spent a half a million
dollars on a study by the school funding
commission to address this problem and I
ask you to please turn your attention to
their report instead of pushing for
privatization programs like H hb20 thank
you very much okay thank you we have I
think we have a question couple
questions
um uh thank you Mr acting chair and
thank you Miss wilky for testifying uh
you mentioned a concern that some uh
non-public schools may have some
textbooks that would be uh may have
material that some would not care for uh
do you think that any
prolation uh or do you think any public
schools currently have any textbooks
that are of serious concern to some
parents uh thank you for your question
I'm not sure who's asking the question I
can't tell by at my screen but it's
representative Mike Moffett oh hi thank
you very much uh I'm sure there are
parents who um disagree with some of the
content for instance maybe some science
content that might just might be in
conflict with their religious beliefs
but at least a public school curriculum
has been approved by the state and it's
it's not a religious curriculum which is
different I think um I also think that
uh as a tax payer I if I felt that a
school was teaching something that was
incorrect and that was prosing some
religious belief I could go to my school
board I could Lobby them I could U run
for school board I have some options I
don't even know I I know I've read some
of the textbooks that some of our
private religious schools use but I have
no way of knowing what they're actually
teaching you know as a as a person that
you're asking to fund them so that's
that's a concern I have thank you thank
you repr
luno question yeah thank you very much
Mr chair and and thank you very much
Miss wilky for joining us this morning
and for taking my question but I was
wondering you you you you mentioned you
talked about student inequities and I I
was wondering if um if you if there's
maybe a COR if there's a correlation
between um um poverty or incidents of
poverty and um and student
outcomes um my I'm I'm a retired teacher
te by the way I don't think I said that
uh yes from what I've read and and I
think reaching H New Hampshire just did
a big study about that that student
poverty is very highly correlated with
um with poor
outcomes thank you very much Miss Wilkey
thank you question um representative MAF
asked basically the same question I
wanted to
ask okay thank you miss Wii uh next have
um Hall Charlie you've been promoted so
go ahead and speak
please yes uh thank you Mr chairman and
uh education committee members my name
is Charles Hall I'm a resident of
national New Hampshire have been for
over 60 years uh two children through
national school system and a grandson
and uh grandchildren and
great-grandchildren currently in public
school system uh across the
state I strongly support House Bill 20
because it provides the bridge between
what we have to what we need new
Hampshire's demographics and student
diversity require an educational system
that will meet the needs of all students
regardless of where they live or
household income this bill will help
break the cycle of poverty to prison
because well-educated students are more
likely to be an asset to society rather
than a burden students thrive in a
learning environment that fits their
needs it builds confidence self-reliance
and stability the benefits of a
well-educated student go away beyond the
classroom well-educated population
attracts businesses good paying jobs
lower crime rate less need for
low-income housing to name a few parents
in New Hampshire should never have to
struggle to get an add adequate
education for their children this bill
provides the resources to help them
educate their children we can pick and
choose the text and the Merit of this
bill but I suggest you look closely at
the benefits and future opportunity for
our
children no one knows what is best for
their children than their parents please
vote Yes so our children can become the
best that they can be thank
you
thank
questions I don't think there are any
questions thank
you okay next we have Kim Carol Kim
please are you
there
okay we will come back to you U Mr
Atherton oh did uh Kim did you come on
sorry Mr
Aon you've been
please can you hear me now yes okay
sorry um my name is U John Atherton and
I have taught for over 40 years
uh so I I have a a a lot of
experience um and uh wide experience I'd
like to urge you to oppose
hb20 for several reasons it uses
taxpayers money to pay for part of the
cost to send children to private schools
states with comparable voucher systems
and it is a voucher system whether
whatever you want to call it reveals the
fact that the rich game the system and
the poor get gamed private teachers need
no certification whatsoever there's no
requirement to test your child's
progress and they can use your our tax
our tax funds as so-called fees for
anything they want and a school gets
full funds if they teach only 51% of the
time what is educational or fair about
hb20 outcomes HB 20 redirects our taxes
to opaque institutions without it
certification and a vague annual
so-called review by a board that
collects a whopping 10% of the EFA fees
in fact hb20 brags that private
institutions have so-called maximum
freedom to one determine your child's
educational needs and two set any
curriculum without review h B20 requires
neither open school board meetings nor
any parent teacher
conferences hb20 supports supporters say
parents not professionals should judge
their child's educational needs parents
may know a child's personal needs but
few know their academic needs too often
parents of children in unprofessional
private schools find out too late that
their child wasted precious months or
years
public scho parents and children need
real help not the hb20 scam reject H
reject hb20 as bad for our children bad
for public schools and bad for New
Hampshire thank you very much I
listening uh I don't see any questions
okay thank you Mr
Aon next we have
Nicole
valano go ahead
Nicole hi there good
morning um I want to say first of all U
thank you to the chair to chair lad and
thank you to the representatives uh on
the Ed committee um this is Nicollet
gagano I'm in do New Hampshire um I have
the perspective of somebody who's lived
in many parts of the state I was brought
up in manad I attended a great public
school there I've lived in The Lakes
Region for 10 years which is where I
brought up my kids and first put them
into public
school now I'm in Dover pursuing a work
opportunity of my husband so we've moved
here to the Sea Coast we really love it
here we've loved it all across the state
though I feel really privileged to have
seen so many parts of our beautiful
state and I'm currently house hunting in
New
Hampshire and I find when I'm looking at
this bill that I'm trying to figure out
what community I should be looking for
should I be looking for a town that has
a private school PR primarily because I
would need to make use of it or should I
be looking for a community that's away
from homeschoolers because I should be
worried about my tax dollars being
siphoned out of the school district and
the fact that my taxes will be on the
chopping
block or should I be looking for a
community that has no private schools
anywhere near it for the highest
investment in the public school that I
would most likely be sending my my
children too it makes me nervous about
how we're going to set our towns up we
already have an issue in this T in this
whole state concerning inequities caused
by the
public and and natural resources of the
community is if you're a community that
has a mountain or a lake or beach front
then you have a robust and deep tax well
to pull from and if you don't have that
then you just have to keep raising taxes
in Hope of meeting the service needs of
your community it's
unsustainable and as a a young family
owner uh young family and who's looking
to be a homeowner again it's it's
disconcerting further I watched the the
last committee on this with um Mr Kelli
who I see is not in with yall today but
he he made a pretty robust and I thought
shocking claim to suggest that families
of wealth who who are already sending
their children to private schools that
they wouldn't bother to take a
$5,000 to $8,000 savings a year per
child and I don't know how he thinks
people get money but miss
Rano yes it's been two minutes wondering
if you could
testimony uh yeah that that's that's it
I I I just I find it laughable to
suggest that that rich folks wouldn't
take every single coupon of nearly
$10,000 per child uh offered to them
that's a it was a crazy claim then and
it should be brought up today and it
should be something that that continues
to be brought up because it was
ridiculous um please vote in expedient
to legislate on this uh and figure out a
new way to fund school because this
isn't
questions thank
Miss next we have Cara mayard um you've
been promoted go ahead please thank you
welcome to the education committee thank
you for having me I also have my three
children who would like to testify so
I'm going to try to go quickly um I just
want to say that I was a product of the
Manchester public school system I
graduated at 15 because they were unable
to meet my needs for advanced education
and we chose to homeschool my children
um because the school systems couldn't
support the needs that they had as well
we've homeschooled them except for last
year for a few months at a charter
school um since they were born and the
money that the state has allocated for
my children is being used by the public
school systems to educate other children
so if that allocation is supposed to be
for my my children why haven't we been
able to access it for classes and other
things like that if the school system is
as efficient as they would like to say
that they are then how come they're not
being able to meet the needs without the
money that is being allocated for my
children from my own taxes so now I'm G
to pass it over to my youngest daughter
hi
love to take classes that would get me
moving and healthier like Arial silks
and I would love to go to programs that
would would help me learn about animals
on
farms and on site at places like ocean
and
ocean
and I would love to attend
classes both online and in person with
places that help me learn to learn
about how to take care of the earth I
would love to visit museums and learn
real life
history in the places it happened and I
would
love to have a new laptop that would
help me to access online classes to be
world your name hi I'm Leah Maynard and
I am testifying for the exact same
reason that you all are so I am
testifying because I believe the state
money for Education should follow the
student I would love to use my money
to allocated for me to enrich aerial
silks no enrich my learning with classes
in specialized science arts and classes
like aerial silks and gymnastics those
are not available to available to me at
the public schools I would be able to
visit more historical sites and access
educational opport unities on site I
would love to have a new laptop that has
upto-date specs for things like art
creation which is one of my passions my
goal is to keep working towards a career
path and helping others and the money
Journey would give me the opportunity to
be better adapt my education for me and
objectives one more one more
[Music]
kidan I would love to get a new laptop
or computer that would allow me to learn
how how to advance coding and
programming I'd love to access classes
like guitar lessons and specialized
computer classes I would love to play
football and there's no football program
offered through our public school I am
interested in engineering and I would
love to be able to access Robotics and
engineering programs in the summer and
during the school year I would I would
also would like to be able to access
mail in in the programs like thumby
thimble that offer coding and robotic
kits with online classes and to assist
with the kids my dream is to be a the a
programmer and for such a specialized
career path the money that is set aside
from the state for me would help me to
reach those
you
sorry
[Laughter]
think any questions
can okay next we have Esther K thank you
for coming to education go ahead
please um I just want to State up front
that I'm against this bill my name is
Esther Kennedy um not only am I the
director of student services for the Gil
Gilford schools I'm also a um City uh
councilwoman for Portsmouth and today um
I just want to ask you folks one
question or maybe
five students on 504 plans
IEP
students foster care
students students with second languages
otherwise known as the so
students students that are
homeless students with mental health
issues students with behavior
issues how does this support those
students and I haven't figured it out
folks in a public school as an
administrator for 22 years working with
students with
Services I have to handle all these
students and I need funding to do
it and I don't see students in these
categories going into this
program so I ask you as my
Representatives how are you going to
make sure that everyone's treated
equal every one has access I'm obligated
under law to make
sure and that everyone's needs are
met I don't see how this program can do
it I am worried that a percentage of
this program is going to an entity
that's not being evaluated by
anyone I also am
worried but who is going to evaluate
these students to make sure they're
learning who's going to make sure these
students are safe because the other
population that I haven't even brought
up is students that are under or they're
been in court
involved you please wrap it up
pleas I'll wrap it up I want to thank
you all but I also want to want you to
all think about these students thank
you any
questions rep leus representative leus
yes thank you for taking my question I
was wondering if all of those students
that you mentioned if their me needs are
currently being met by the traditional
um local public school why would a
parent remove them from that where
things were working for
them I I do not believe a parent will
remove him from my school my many of our
parents agree that are their needs are
being met however I do
believe that that um I don't have any
students I know someone use the term out
of District placement I don't have any
students in my school district out of
District place right now because we work
really
hard but I do believe that if we're
going to provide something that sends
money to another place it should be open
to all people and I haven't figured out
how a child and foster care system will
have access to this program I haven't
figured out how a family that um has an
ESO student will have access to this
program so if our funding is going to go
there my tax dollars is going to go
there then everyone should be able to
have access so parents if we're truly
talking about choice they should have
choice so if they want to leave my
district to go they should have it but I
think that you need make sure we have to
have
access um I
guess I'm not
sure I'm not sure your point is if needs
are being met as you said and you don't
have children wanting to go I'm not sure
what your objection is because nobody's
forcing people to go any place else so
it seems that the only people that would
take this up would be people whose needs
weren't being
met Am I Wrong oh I don't think you're
wrong representative but what I do think
that if a percentage of the distri
students in my district want to
go um that might not um be in those
categories but Matt gives less money for
those kids in my district to receive
Services we won't have the f as much
funding thank
you
Tanner Tanner Tanner uh thank you Mr
chair for uh taking my question and
thank you Miss Kennedy for coming today
um as you stated you think that there
would be less money to help these
children that are left at school if if
in fact the ones that are left behind
are the ones uh 504 I AP that sort of
thing do you think that um funding based
on Distributing to schools based on not
only economic status but also the
expense that may be incurred with uh
students who need uh special services
I'm sorry representative ten are you are
you saying it would be more fair if they
could go or more fair if they if we
didn't do funding would be more fair if
it was distributed from the state based
on um outcomes and also on the real
costs of educating students um students
that are homeless students that need
IEPs
Etc I think it would always be fair if
we could distribute the appropriate
funding from federal and state um there
would be some more fairness but I also
believe that if we take from our
districts it'll become more difficult to
fund those programs for our most needy
you re luno re
luno representative luno ask your
question please thank you very much Mr
chair so and and thank you Miss Kennedy
for joining us this morning um on page
four of the bill um Roman
3 it says um the scholarship
organization shall ensure that parents
of students with disabilities receive
notice that participation in the EFA
program is is a parental placement I'm
sorry Council representative Lun I
couldn't hear what saying oh c can't
hear me I'm sorry um can you hear me now
yes yeah so so so it um um on on page
five I'm sorry page four of the bill
down at the bottom of the page on Roman
three and I'm trying to read it on
another screen so I'm try to get you
know be in proximity of the microphone
and the text it says the scholarship
organization shall ensure that parents
of students with disabilities receive
notice that participation in the EFA
program is a parental placement under 20
USC section 1412
individuals with disabilities Education
Act along with an explanation of the
rights that parentally placed students
possess under idea and any applicable
state laws what does all that
mean um well I I think what we need to
say is that when a child is placed by a
parent um it's questionable depending on
the situation on whether the district
has to support eventually making sure
that placement um meet the child's
educational needs or whether the
district um does not have to and the
parent loses re um supports from the
public school for the student with
special needs my concern is both ways
one is if a parent is placed and we find
that we have to provide will that
institution or will that um placement be
able to support the children with these
needs if we uh don't have to provide
services my concern is will the child
get the services they need to be
successful um and will the child will
the parent in that other institution
where the money is going provide a child
and help them through their educational
um support so they become a citizen that
can actively participate in our society
and I think that's what we're all trying
to do is create citizens for the future
Kennedy that I see okay okay thank you
for your testimony and next okay thank
all for your
work next we have Lindsay peard go ahead
Lindsay I promoted you welcome to
Ed good morning thank you um for the
record my name is Lindsay Pickard I am
here today representing myself as a
lifelong resident of New Hampshire and
product of the public education system
as well as my district which is SAU
number 94 um where I currently sit as
the school board chair thank you for uh
your time today and allowing me the
opportunity to testify regarding my
opposition to House Bill 20 um much of
what I had written today has already
been stated so in order to be as
efficient as possible I will just
provide one uh little analogy and then
some support um the education funding
issue in New Hampshire kind of reads
like a yo-yo diet blog since the
Claremont decision more than 20 years
ago and to dat residents of New
Hampshire have been losing and gaining
valuable funding for their respective
districts kind of like we've been
watching infomercials on how to get
education funding
quickly the legislation has pitched
quick fixes like annual stop gaps to
current budget losses and some of my
favorites like last year the gimmick
one-time infrastructure adequacy c a
don't get used to it it'll be gone next
year if you're me you can almost hear
that in Billy May's voice pitching his
cell at 2 am ultimately there has been
some phenomenal data provided by Barett
Christina from the New Hampshire School
Board Association as well as um some
really good information from mayor Jim
um dones I apologize if I mispronounced
his last name and some uh information
from General en residents some with
retired teachers some longtime Council
people within our uh great state the
bottom line is
this while I agree that there will never
be a one-size fits
all I urge you as this at this level to
itl this bill and work harder to solve
the original problem the education
funding formula for the State of New
Hampshire if we put half as much into
solving that problem perhaps the public
education system would have a greater
ability to meet the needs of all of the
students and
families when I listened to this hearing
last week I noted that at that time
there were approximately 600 in favor
and over 3,000 opposed to the bill I
think that gives us a pretty good
snapshot as to the benefits of public
education and yet does highlight a need
to do even better which is I think
something that we're all striving for in
the end thank you for your time I will
submit my uh full testimony in writing
repeated representative M ask question
please thank you Mr Aton chair and thank
you Mr Picard uh I don't notice from
your testimony from your comments that
you have a obviously a history and
commitment to public education as as I
think do most of the us as well uh you
being a Schoolboard member but I'd like
to ask you and I would ask others this
too as as we go along uh the the 60s the
70s the 80s even the 1990s they just
seem to be to me and I was around for
those decade such a broad basis of
support for public schools that I have
seen change I think we've all seen Chang
AO we have this these movements for
homeschooling and for school choice and
and movement to to private schools uh
can you share maybe just one insight as
to why this this major change has come
about in terms of attitudes and support
for public schools you being a a board
member so just to clarify you're you're
wondering if I have some insight as to
why there's been a shift in uh such
dedication to public education versus
opportunity for other education sure if
you could just maybe give us one Insight
from your perspective as to why there's
been such a dramatic shift in attitudes
in the last couple
decades uh I think technology has a lot
to do with our shift in in that Focus we
have such a great ability to be in touch
with opportunities outside of just our
immediate Community our um you know our
ability to tap into other States other
countries other people uh that we might
not have a relationship with in our
immediate Community I think has opened
up the eyes to many that um we
have we could have a better way of
educating youth ac across the board and
across the
much
luno representative luno ask question
thank you very much Mr chair and thank
you very much um Mard for joining us
this morning and for your work on the
Winchester um um SAU 94 board uh boy the
folks in Winchester work really hard to
support their schools tax rate close to
$35 um per thousand um you talked about
uh looking at other approaches for um
for funding public education and um
would you believe that um that that that
other approach could uh could continue
to support the high quality uh school
system that that you operate and um and
reduce the property tax on Winchester um
property taxpayers by more than $12 per
thousand well if you're speaking about
SB 158 I already have a note here that I
am absolutely interested in learning
more about Alternatives I think that our
our tax rate actually
um it is in it is indicative of a
property poor area of New Hampshire and
on the surface it looks like we are
indeed offering above and beyond an
adequate education but really that tax
rate only shows you what we're able to
scrape by because of um
our area uh and our you know we don't we
don't have a
mountain we don't have another Revenue
generating
opportunity thank you thank you very
much Miss Picard thank you any further
questions Mr
wood Mr uh representative Woodcock
representative Woodcock ask your
question please thank you Mr acting
chair uh Mr farar thank you for taking
my question and I appreciate the fact
that you've been listening because my
comments go to a prior speaker you
indicated that uh you think the problem
with the education system is the uh the
bouncing of the financial ball and how
we fund education uh and that should be
the how we address this although the
prior speaker indicated that french
fries McDonald's and competition and
widgets was the way to go so I want to
know if you had a response to
that yeah I I do indeed actually I've
heard that I've heard something similar
uh along a lot of this testimony I have
been listening for many hours to it I
think it's a travesty that we are that
that we are
uh making decisions about education
driving it on profit when somebody
profits from education there stands to
be a loss to another party so I think
line of properly educating our
chairman okay than you card thank you
m our next speaker is Derek Trembley go
ahead
Derek thank you chairman thank you house
committee I understand that you are also
in receipt of perhaps two of my written
testimonies and uh in the effort to make
use of the time I do want to Echo much
of what Miss Kate Baker deur mentioned
to start the day um and then I thought
it might be helpful so I have to
identify who I am as well sorry about
that I am the Headmaster of Mount R
Academy I'm a resident of Goan uh we are
a private Catholic Independent School uh
we are also incorporated as a nonprofit
501c3 and according to the attorney
general because we just barely make more
than $1 million a year in our gross
receipts we are subject to a financial
audit to make sure that we are
accountable at least in a fiscal sense
um our budget just in case people don't
know how private schools operate
sometimes uh we spend about $1.1 million
a year in tuition Revenue we take in
anywhere between $650 and $700,000 a
year and then because of the amount of
need-based financial aid we give out we
have to fund raise anywhere between
between 350 and
$450,000 a year um so it's a very tight
operation in that sense uh I do want to
read from our policy regarding
discrimination since that's been a huge
part of the conversation I hope that you
will hear the authenticity of my mouth
and my language uh because I don't know
that people are really hearing uh that
we don't discriminate and uh so I'm just
going to read this for you okay it says
we welcome students of any race Creed
color and National or ethnic origin each
student is entitled to the same rights
privileges programs and activities
available to all students of the school
we do not discriminate on the basis of
race color or national and ethnic origin
in administration of any of our
policies um and then on top of that too
because I think discrimination usually
pivots on are we open to accepting
students who may be
um of a higher you know learning need
who have needs that uh require more work
more effort more attention and we
certainly are um a
nice element of our reopening plan
because we wanted to stay in person was
that we hired more par Educators which
is trbl could you please wrap it up yes
I will wrap up and just say that we do
serve students who are on any type of
IEP ISP 504 plan thank
you
we have a question from representative
Woodcock yeah I'm open to that question
thank you representative Woodcock yes um
representative Milo had his hand up
before me I'll yield to
him U thank you Mr chairman and thank
you for taking my question um Mr Trum
I'm assuming that you have reviewed um
House Bill 20 and uh would you agree
that there is no anti-discrimination
language in this bill as it sits right
now is that correct correct and I've got
a followup too all right thank you so to
to my knowledge uh representative the
way the the funding works is it funds
the child not the school and it funds
the family not the school so I I would
imagine that that's not in the bill
because it it's not about the school as
much as it's about the
child thank you very much you're correct
in that and I think that's one of the
ways that uh there's an attempt here to
get around the issue of
anti-discrimination language but here's
the other question I have do you think
that it's appropriate that if I send my
child to a Christian school and they
discover that the my child is
gay and they dismiss him from that
school do you think that's appropriate
using tax dollars to fund that
tuition well so again I I want to make
sure that it goes to the child first to
answer that question I mean our mission
is that we believe all children are made
in the image and likeness of God and
that they they should be treated
therefore as such so dismissal on
grounds such as those that you mentioned
would not really I think be a good way
of treating that child um I think that
there needs to be uh an a conversation
with the parents in which you
know it shouldn't go there I guess I'm
gonna I'm gonna I'm G to leave it there
if that's okay I hope that keeps it nice
and short and simple for you yeah I and
I think that's that's the issue that I I
have because if I want my child to have
a Christian education but they happen to
be trans gender for example uh and
they're rejected using tax dollars do
you think that's
fair I think that at least I'll speak
from our school is that okay and how we
that's that's that's correct okay yeah I
I I'll speak from our school because I
want people to hear there's a lot of
allegations out there about how we think
right um we we have to work with all
state laws and regulations and and I
think that we also need to act on a
higher plane than that too but
fundamentally we will work with any
parent and student who desire to come to
our
school thank you very much thank you any
further question representative wood C
Sanders and uh representative mull
representative
Woodcock thank you Mr chairman Mr try
thank you for taking my question uh I I
started to write down uh when you were
speaking if you're private Catholic
independent 501c3 and I start to write
down your your goals the emission piece
and and I get to the race call a
national origin but I didn't hear
anything there about uh students who are
gay lesbian bisexual transgender I heard
none of that in your statement about
Mission acceptance so if my daughter
who's transgender wanted to attend your
school and made that my son made that uh
aware of you to you in your mission
accept admission board prior to
admission would you accept them so so
let me be clear I guess it's kind of the
same answer as the last time if that's
okay we will work with any parent and
child who genuinely desires to come to
our school and usually what we find sir
two U representative is they want to
come to our school because they believe
in our mission they want to come to our
school because they're seeking placement
here so I think that that's like the the
bigger conversation rather than just
trying to say it's about this other
thing and that's been our experience
I've been here for for 10 years
representative every parent that I've
seen they want to send their child here
and then we work with them to the extent
that they want to send their child here
because they believe in the mission of
the school to followup Mr chairman yep
so your your answer then is that you
would not exclude my son or daughter if
you knew going in they were
transgender we would I'm just going to
say it this way if they want to be here
then I know that they believe in the
mission of the school so we will work
with them to the extent that they
believe in the mission of the school and
chairman thank you Mr chair and thank
you Mr Trembley for taking my question
um you advertised yourself as a Catholic
school so uh my I have a two-part
question one is um do you have an
obligation to upholding the beliefs and
practices of the Catholic church in your
governance
and two what role do parents play in
your the governance of your school in
other words uh if representative
woodcock's transgendered daughter is at
your school is there some sort of
governance board that could weigh in on
whether or not that child is in
attendance yeah um can I go with the
second question first so sure yeah we we
do have an independent board of
directors that that I report to to um
and I as because we're incorporating the
state of New Hampshire as a
501c3 um they you know they they have to
I think live within a certain geographic
area of where we are um we have policies
and procedures much like public schools
because some of those are just really
good practices and um parents are very
involved um it's actually interesting
here a lot of people wonder why we don't
have a PTO of some kind and that's cuz
parents are here every day and and that
is the nature of a
of a partnership in in this setting
between a private school and those
parents the parents obviously are
sacrificing to send their child there um
and two your other question I believe
about upholding the teachings of the
Catholic church is that correct that was
the first one yeah yeah yeah so we're
we're very authentic in that and we're
faithful in that sense and and we do
believe in the fullness of what the
church teaches um we get the question
all the time and I've done probably
thousands of Tours before you would
imagine do I have to be this to to be
here and we always say no we are who we
are and if the church is universal we
love all people um and if you really
desire to be here then I'm sure you're
going to want to work with us and we're
going to want to work with you um so I
hope that answers your
question thank
you thank you Mr chair and thank you Mr
try for taking my question um first if I
may I'd like to thank you on be thank
the Catholic schools on behalf of my
apist friends who T because with I know
quite a few atheists that actually
Delight me going to Catholic schools my
question is if you're aware of the I
think it said B the gay lesbian and
straight education Network work that
they've done over the last two decades
and their most recent 2020 survey showed
a higher rate of U bullying harassment
and assault of LBT lb lgbtq students in
public district schools and private Rel
schools and I'm wondering if you're
seeing students coming from the public
schools in order to be safer within your
Halls yeah I don't know if I could speak
to the the specifics of like are they
are they because of their their
treatment and perhaps some of what
they're dealing with is that why they
come here um yeah but we do have
children who come here because they they
I could tell that they fear if they were
in a public school they would be treated
differently um that's not every child
who comes here though and uh I guess I I
don't want to say that it's always the
case that in those four walls that are
not these four walls these things are
going to happen right but um we we do
have anecdotal situations where people
students come here because they feel
safer
here thank you Mr acting chair and thank
you uh Mr trom for for testifying and
taking time to be here uh the bla
Amendment I'm sure you're familiar with
goes back to the 1880s and many States
including New Hampshire have versions of
the Blain Amendment which precludes
public money to go to secular sectarian
Catholics basically he aimed at
Catholics uh schools it was probably uh
a great example of 19 century Prejudice
now the espanosa versus Montana case
last year US Supreme Court has o
overturned that so there a whole new
landscape of which I'm sure you're quite
familiar but my question is are you
aware that Canada has a very long
tradition of directing public money to
Catholic schools did you know that yeah
so I'm
aware um of of that I'm aware that
America may be one of the few countries
that do not take advantage of the
Catholic School System um most of Europe
has traditionally probably Canada does
um the bla amendments I'm also aware of
the good thing is that you are all
elected to discuss those very weighty
things all the time I'm just trying to
educate
children so um yeah and and obviously
you could make the argument that's a
double standard and things like that but
um for me we're just trying to do the
next right thing by the kid who comes in
front of us so I'll take that as a yes
you do know that Canada gives public
money to Catholic schools thank you so
much yeah I am aware of that in America
I'll I'll say this is one of the few
that I mean just Statewide we don't have
a a uniform um policy on that at a
federal level for sure okay thank you Mr
try I'm wrap up the questions because we
need to move on okay uh do you see that
rep has his hand up
rep gonna move on move on thank you Mr
thank you all very much okay and uh
next we have um Miss Leslie want go
ahead Leslie you're uh next up on
education thank you
gosh she's coming no I'm sorry that I'm
Sorry Miss W go ahead please that's okay
that scared me I've been on here for six
and a half hours now since between last
week and today I that oh my gosh it was
my turn and there I go anyway thank you
right
um
video maybe if you turn off your video
try that does that help is that better
yes okay um um so thank you committee
for hearing my testimony U my name is
Leslie want and I am the vice chair of
the board of school committee here in
Manchester New Hampshire and I'm here to
to express my deep concern over house
Bell 20 and its certain impact on public
education in New Hampshire and more
specifically the detrimental effect it
will have on the Manchester public
school system our school districts
already facing a precipitous budget
shortfall due to already declining
enrollment predominantly due the
pandemic as well as a substantial $2.6
million increase in retirement costs
from the state the Hampshire school
funding commission has highlighted the
fact that the current school funding
system has created vast inequities
between communities all across our state
and highlighted how many local taxpayers
are expected to compensate for lack of
wealth in their community in order to
provide their children with the same
adequate education as a wealthier
community this is further exacerbated in
the state's largest city where we have a
tax cap that prevents investment in
schools even when there's a s Surplus in
Revenue house spill 20 will widen these
inequities and create far and create
large population of children finding
themselves further from educational
Economic Opportunity by diverting
funding from our public schools to
private schools and homeschoolers
unfortunately the family of a Beach
Street Schools students
the poorest School in New Hampshire as
far as a high high percentage of student
students with unframe reduced lunch um
will most likely not be able to re
afford the remainder of a tuition bill
after applying their Esa funds and the
private school will still remain Out Of
Reach the children will then remain at
Beach Street but with far fewer
resources for that school to use for
multi-tiered systems of support
textbooks and teach teachers this bill
will leave New Hampshire already
struggling public schools with larger
class sizes fewer supports and no
ability to address outdated school
buildings thereby creating a greater
disparity between the Haves and the Have
Nots the disparity disp
disproportionately impacts communities
of color and is a form of discrimination
why not spend our energy and our time
and resources to fix education for all
New Hampshire students let's let's if
you feel public schools are falling
short don't sell them out but instead
Shore them up let's work to make them
the best in the nation because New
Hampshire could do that with the support
of all of its leaders thank you you've
exceeded the time uh much any uh do we
have any questions representative M
thank you Mr R shair thank you m Juan
for your testimony I I just got a a text
message from uh a Manchester uh resident
uh I guess a former School official and
she just wanted uh us to ask you about
the Manchester budget being millions of
dollars over the tax cap despite a
thousand kids uh pulling out of the
district this is from her message so I I
don't know if those are the the right
numbers but could you speak to being
millions of dollars over the tax cap
despite a thousand kids calling out of
the district
how is that
relevant yeah I'm little bit questioning
the um the question as well tax cap is
um is um not a I'm sorry um it doesn't
really the tax cap this seems like a
non-er question this is not relevant to
the to to hp20 whatsoever right you've
overruled other questions so I would I
would suggest this is not relevant at
what whatever Mr chairman how is this
relevant agre I agree yeah thank you m
chair I passed this question I believe
the intent of this message that was just
sent to me had to do with the the the
current efficiency and efficacy of of uh
the public schools in in uh in Miss
want's district and to give her a chance
to speak to uh that that person should
call her up and ask her
not I'd be happy to address this um so
thank you do we have the lowest per
pupil spending in the entire state of
any of any school district that that
maintains elementary middle and high
schools um we are incredibly underfunded
given the fact that our students have
the greatest needs we have the highest
percentages of students with free
reduced launch the highest number of
students that are English language
Learners and also the highest percentage
of students that are special needs
students so we have a great number of
needs in Manchester and they have been
undermat not because of the local
taxpayer the local taxpayer has done
their share we have tried very hard but
um it is difficult when you have do have
a tax cap for one and when you don't
have the um resources like a l like
previous speakers have said we don't
have a lake near us we don't have high
property valuation so because we are
sort of middle Ro property valuation the
amount our taxpayers pay in order to
fund an adequate education in Manchester
is is
considerable and um and inadequate
still thank you very much for that uh
useful perspective appreciate
it
l representative M question Lun I'm
sorry represent Luna you have a question
thank you very much Mr chair and and
thank you very much um Miss la for uh
for being with us today and for for all
of your efforts on the um the the um
Manchester school committee uh that's a
that's a very important job and one of
the things you you referred to in your
testimony was this projected um
reduction in the state Grant to the
Manchester School District uh in the
amount of about $12 million and I was
wondering if you could sort of speak to
that the importance of House Bill 623
and Senate bill 14
in in addressing that
shortfall sure um so any money that
Manchester gets is sorely needed I will
say though that the money that comes in
through some of these bills is one-time
money and doesn't help fix a lot of our
problems which are Staffing problems and
programmatic problems um and not onetime
spending problems so I will say it
concerns me when we want to when we want
to solve problems in New Hampshire less
by looking at the overall way way funds
public schools and look more at one-time
Solutions of like throwing this this
little bag of money at a problem and
that little bag of money at a problem
not that millions of dollars is a little
bag of money but but it doesn't begin to
compare to the the um the issues that we
face um to in order to give all of our
students the best education possible and
equitable
education thank thank you very much Miss
W represent sh you have a question yes
it's it's a would you believe but first
of all Lesley um is one of the finest
school board members that we've ever had
Manchester and I have great respect for
her and and what she believes in and how
hard she works for uh the students in
the teachers in Manchester and she's
also a friend and Wesley it's good to
have you here
um I I'd like to just kind of would you
believe uh with you would you believe
that if we had a good adequacy funding
formula that was
consistent and that was providing the
amounts of money throughout the the the
uh state that education would improve
all over the state including Manchester
and then if that were in place and if
that was happening then school choice
would have a place somewhere along the
line um but it would not be taking away
from uh the um the students and uh the
education throughout our
state thank you Barbara for the question
um and please I can't hear you hone so
repres representative Shaw thank you for
the question and can you hear me
now yes okay
um I just wanted to say uh I I think if
we adequately funded education across
the state that then school choice could
occur Even in our within our own
District we have 22 schools I think if
we they were all adequately funded and a
school down on Beach Street wasn't
different than a school on Smith Road
that we could allow you know even school
choice with in our school district which
it doesn't happen now I um I believe
that students need to to have what what
each individual student needs charter
schools are fine they're Public Schools
but I think giving money to um private
schools and home schools is is full
hearty and I have to say on a personal
note as a as a person who's taught
religious side in the Catholic church at
the Cathedral here for 23 years years I
do not want my Tex dollars spent on um
Catholic schools sending sending to
Catholic school thanks Lesley thank you
further
questions thank you a Miss want okay
next speaker is uh Lily uh and I believe
it Lily Williams is your last name um
you're you've been promoted go ahead and
speak thank you and please keep your
testimony in two minutes thank you can
you hear me
yes hi my name is Lily Tong Williams I'm
new in New Hampshire moved here from
Colorado and uh also I grew up in China
you all know People's Republic of China
where parents had no choices we had only
one school to go to the government
schools and the home school schools were
recently banned even though there were
only small amount of students who could
not get adequate education and who have
health mental issues to stay home to be
homeschooled so anyway lots of
immigrants came to America I just wanted
to tell you that because America is
still The Shining hell on the city for
Freedom that freedom includes freedom to
choose parental rights are the
fundamental
rights otherwise
our kids will be just like China belong
to the state belong to the Villages then
you have the certain political class of
people to determine that what they
should learn how they should learn
instead of our kids should be focus our
education the quality education today is
a no longer I feel like the focus of our
Public Schools we have seen enough of
that during the shutdowns right lots of
kids come home cannot get adequate
education except the rich like Governor
newon can send his kids go to private
schools in person but our public school
kids lots of immigrant kids are stuck at
home and have mental crisis and their
parents had to work left them home alone
so there are lots of story like that so
this is New Hampshire I just wanted to
share my story with you that you will
see America and still a country for for
freedom to choose and still for parents
rights we are not China yet so I
strongly support this bill and I urge
you to vote for this bill you you're
happy stay with where you are in public
school but people who are not happy
especially people who need money to do
the choices they need make that decision
for themselves we're not here to judge
parents what do they want for their kid
because you don't know their kids they
know their kid and they belong the kids
belong to the parents thank you if you
have any questions I'll be very happy to
answer that thank you L um do we have
members seeing none thank you very much
today um we were going to take a break
yeah we were going to take a break uh
I'm not sure um how long that break will
be for um but uh want to say 12:30 at
12:10 make it a half an hour yeah make
it 30 minutes for our break and um so
we'll see you about
12:40 I apologize for my English I think
I say something wrong should be The
Shining City on the hell right
yes shining hell on the city sorry about
that it's my English is my second
language thank you I do that with my
first
see 12:45 did we say okay I'm just gonna
tell
Jen
you
brought
Sor representative
MF could you check on
our oh never mind I'll I'll do
it
came
well
good
for
[Music]
T
in this is a bad idea to put this in
legislation and go after them in legisl
go
girls we need to show you some get you
beans I'm G get a
quick got okay you get through I'm going
to go do that right now and I wanted to
get the file that's what I came out here
for I have my information on there to
log in okay to my GM right there it is
okay so just so you know I'm taking this
right this file now I'm going put
everything in here so it's all here
stuff I can't I would love to Darling
but I can't
okay maybe maybe tonight can be a giant
[Music]
you
I
am
I gotta go upstairs with s to change
okay
Toby
myal
made
it
Ming
rby
some
[Music]
go
are
[Music]
hello
yeah oh you tried to get pict your
screen I don't know how
to
I do have a
woman who texted me and I'm wondering if
I can
she's member of the public can she go so
or
[Music]
no
screen
you
Jen uh no I
yeah I just texted her and asked if she
down
thank
there okay everybody ready for the next
speaker oh I'm sorry have audio with
remote repr for can you hear
me
okay we can hear you okay thank you very
she okay I'd like to go ahead with HB 20
our house hearing um we will continue
down the list which is of people that
sign up to today following that we'll
bounce back to the list we had the other
day and try to work through it finding
the people see if they're with us are
not with us so with that ripson Hopson
who do we have next that's uh one of the
today's signups um oh uh we have Kelly
Potenza she signed up uh last week I'm
sorry I already queued her up when fine
let's just get it going go ahead U Miss
Penza you're to
education hi can you hear me yes we can
I had prepared uh my own statement but
um a fellow a fellow friend of mine that
is a um a school teacher actually asked
me to read her statement um and just the
reason why is mainly because for fear of
Retribution she didn't um she can't say
she's I'm writing um so this is good
afternoon I'm writing to share with you
why after 15 years of teaching in the
New Hampshire school system I am in
total support of hb20 I'm a decorated
teacher holding multiple degrees
certifications and many years of
experience working within several of my
District's professional committees I am
a mentor teacher within the district
where I am often paired up with newly
hired Educators and I have also opened
my classroom up to college level
students I had the pleasure of teaching
across several different grade levels
and I also teach education classes for
one of the state's well-known
universities to say that education is a
part of who I am would be an
understatement I feel it is important
that this be known by all in attendance
today and that it is there and that
there has been a major shift in
education in the last three to five
years and that this shift is trending
away from concrete instruction and
shifting towards a focus more on the
students social emotional needs SL
behaviors and teachers learning and
implementing instructional programs it
is my opinion that we have especially
moved away from decomposing standards
time well spent in collaborative
meetings awareness of what students need
to know by the end of the year along
with rigorous direct instruction to
teaching Educators how to teach programs
and curriculums that move students along
far too quickly and leave zero time for
managing small group instruction which
would be specific to students needs our
Title One programs don't move students
through quickly I don't believe the
model is being implemented the way it
should be and classroom teachers are not
able to give skilled specific
instruction to students with gaps due to
uh an overwhelmingly full plate of this
concept of more more more these children
are becoming lifelong tital wers instead
of solidifying unknowns and moving on
with grade level instruction students
are continuing to fall farther and
farther behind year after year and
schools are just allowing this and
sending them through to the next year
teachers are learning something new
every couple of years instead of
mastering quality instruction for the
standards they are responsible for at
their grade level districts are
spending I'm sorry your your time has
expired we're happy to receive the
remainder of the testimony by email all
right I will send it to you via email um
thank you very much thank you very much
are you willing to take questions yeah
I'll take
questions
Kelly yes do you have a question I do
yes yes um uh thank you for taking my
question and thank you Mr chair I was
just wondering um Miss Penza if um I
think I don't want to assume but you're
uh feeling the same sentiments uh are
you an
educator uh I'm not an educator but um
I'm feeling yep I'm feeling the exact
same sentiments my personal testimony
was going to be more so of what I've had
to deal with in regards with my own two
children and um and just knowing that I
that I know that school choice is
essential and it really needs to come
from parent parents um there was another
statement I was going to read from my
girlfriend that is a former teacher she
just left during the pandemic in
Rochester she's a math teacher and she
literally says the same exact things
that are here and um was there working
in that system for the last five years
and the stories are absolutely appalling
and there are this isn't about this
really isn't at all about um you know
vouchers and and taking anything away
from the public schools and I believe
there are so many amazing Public School
teachers that want this too so this is
about choice and this is about what's
best for kids and uh that's what that's
why it needs to happen something needs
to change here and maybe this will make
things change Miss Penza uh would you
please uh submit that written testimony
to the uh clerk represent Barb Shaw here
and we'll make sure that gets in the
record thank you very much all right
sorry I'm looking for the next speaker
okay we do have
Spencer okay go
ahead
Spencer he we're trying to inform all
folks that are testifying that we're
trying to keep the testimony down two
minutes
resp
question oh you didn't
okay is she there yep she's there um you
can unmute Miss
Spencer she goes okay I thank you um Mr
chair for taking my uh testimony today
and to all of the committee members for
listening um to the Public's um
viewpoints on on this bill um I think
this bill should be called the dismantle
Public Schools act because with New
Hampshire school districts facing
unprecedented challenges due to the
current funding crisis and the added
burdens of covid uh we're talking about
pulling money out of that very stress
system we're in a perfect storm and this
bill quite frankly could be the gust of
wind that wipes some of our smaller
Local Schools right off the map um I
keep hearing that zip code should not
Define a child's future and I completely
agree with this sentiment I just come to
a very different conclusion about how we
best serve each child I believe we do
that by investing our resources funding
and energy into making Public Schools
the very best they can be um and not
diverting tax dollars only when
necessary to make very specific need
needs of individual children shouldn't
all our kids have internet and computer
enrichment opportunities and engaged
learning I don't want to see these
things just reserved for those who might
have parents that can help them navigate
school vouches um as a taxpayer I
request that this committee seek
independent financial analysis of this
bill's impact the scenarios presented by
commissioner adal blute seemed wildly
unrealistic to me why wouldn't every
parent with a child currently
homeschooling or in private schools and
we heard 20,000 today approximately why
wouldn't they apply for this money and
withdraw it from our local
districts as Finance chairman Neil Kirk
said in reference to SB 193 and that was
a bill that was much more conservative
in breath than hb20 after it went
through committee he said I was not
elected to downshift costs on my
constituents so I cannot support this
bill I think that applies to SB uh hb20
I'm sorry um and I would just say that
to those who vote for this bill that
they lose the claim to be fiscal
conservatives or Defenders of the New
Hampshire taxpayer because this bill
diverts money right away from taxpayers
and shifts the cost down to local
districts so I thank you for taking my
testimony um I will be happy to take any
questions Spencer are there
questions seeing No Hands thank you very
much thank
you okay next we have Scott Rose uh Mr
education uh I don't have him did you
oh you know what I think you're
right um Mr gross I'm sorry I did have
you as already having testified so I'm
have okay Doris go ahead
uh I see that you're scheduled to speak
you've been promoted go ahead
please are you available to talk am I
just had to figure out how to unmute it
the whole screen went blank and then I
came back very strange I'm darus hoeny
I'm a mother of six I homeschooled my
could you could you speak up please we
can't hear you okay my name is darus
heny I'm a mother of six homeschooled
children I'm a former board member from
Nash repres presenting myself I favor
choice but I oppose this bill it
undermines the independence of private
education it will it has to it's our tax
dollars we need accountability it will
also introduce an income tax or
broad-based tax because you're adding a
hundred million dollars to the adequacy
of private education so this is not the
solution this is a centralized solution
we need to decentralize I believe in the
public schools and I believe there
there's a model in Canada Edmonton
Canada that has um an alternate learning
program that's been operation for 25
years they have listed online and in my
test my testimony which I submitted I've
got the link there's over 27 programs
that they've got from Arts to music to
bilingual education to science where
they have choice in the schools they
have communities of parents and they set
them up I'd recommend that we have
little school boards over each School
building and we create those communities
create the choice that parents are
looking for because they're screaming to
get out of the schools especially with
remote they're screaming to get out
because they see what the kids are
learning in terms of social emotional
learning instead of basic academics so
some want out they want Alternatives
give it to them in the schools we don't
have to continue with this centralized
approach you need a a limited Choice a v
a voice right there at your schools we
fix oh I'm sorry I guess I'm done oh I
got 15 15 seconds when we fixed the home
education law it went from 1990 to 2012
it took 22 years for parents to join
together to fix that parents can't fix
this you have to enable them to have a
voice to fix their own schools and
do thank you very much dor are you
willing to take questions
committee I don't see any thank you very
much
see any committee members asking
questions you're wel thank you okay so
next we have
Natalie uh quo um you've been promoted
go ahead please and
unmute is my volume okay committee yes
that's great great thank you good
afternoon Mr chair and committee members
my name is Nal Gedo and I am from
Winchester I'm testifying on behalf and
I um on behalf of myself and I'm in
opposition to this bill hb20 our school
budget in town was cut by $1.6 Million
last year by a group of people whose
mentality and goal is to have zero
government control throughout the state
this bill supports that effort zero
government control which is spelled out
in the bill under 194 e-7 Roman numeral
2 our town is still fighting to this day
with each other over that cut passing
this bill will tear our community apart
further by supporting their efforts in
giving money to private schools under
the mask of a savings account
this bill takes our children and divides
them into private institutions by
throwing money at parents in hopes of
them leaving the public education system
is also not appealing to lower income
individuals like most of the folks in
Winchester who may not have a way to get
their children for a private school or a
child or their child who may not even be
accepted to the school either this bill
basically segregates our population in
Winchester and tears our community apart
stripping every child of their
connection to their neighbors community
and the government as a whole this bill
also devalues our long history of
education an institution older than
anyone listening to me speak right now
our history needs to be saved this bill
will hurt our school and it is just
another nail in the coffin of killing
the Winchester's public school system I
would think that in a room of elected
officials that you would agree that this
bill effectively takes away the control
of the governing bodies of New Hampshire
and puts our tax dollars taxpayer money
into the hands of private institutions
was which is exactly what that group in
our town aimed to do when they cut
Winchester their school budget the
gentleman also the gentleman who spoke
earlier mentioned that the Catholic
School school system does not
discriminate what that does not mean is
that they do do not IND Doctrine so in
the town like Winchester whose schools
will shut down that means that our
low-income students will have no other
choice but to attend a private school
while they will try to indoctrinate them
with their values and missions thus not
supporting a free and fair Education
Without discrimination there is no other
option for Winchester please please itl
this bill and save my community thank
you Mr chair I'm happy to take any
questions from the committee thank you
very much
Mr are there any
much okay next Mr chair uh we're looking
for speaker Amy goodr uh there is an Amy
in the chat I'm hoping you are the same
Amy are you prepared to speak I am
actually not Amy goodr but I would love
to
speak right ahead okay all right so my
name is Amy Shaw I am from Rochester New
Hampshire um I am a wife twice now a
mother of five children two biologically
all of us with special individual needs
my story is very long so I'm just going
to give you the basis of who we are and
you can ask me any question you want um
that pertains to any of those so um I am
a adult who went to public school and
private school I sent my nine-year-old
now to Catholic school we are not
Catholic um when she was five we had to
get a lot of Assessments and testing
done we found that she had a lot of
special needs um I pulled my daughter
from private school in C to public
school because what I thought was that
they were going to be able to help her
she would be able to get an IEP a 504
that's what I was hearing from a lot of
Professionals in my community um that is
not what
happened my
daughter is one that fell through the
cracks I feel like there are those with
um extreme special needs there are those
who don't there are those who are very
poor there are those who are
not like I feel like sometimes the
middle ground just gets lost so I fought
for a year and a half to try and help my
daughter get the education that she
deserved a free and you know reasonable
or whatever it is the fap education um
all we got was stress
anxiety um you know my daughter was
doing horribly she was put in danger
twice in the public school system and
publicly humiliated by her teacher um
and when I fought I got nowhere I went
to the states I went to nonprofits um
they all couldn't believe my story so
after a couple years in the Public
School at Rochester hi everyone in
Rochester they know who I am um I was at
a witsen I didn't know what I was going
to do I said I'm gonna have to
homeschool or go back to private we were
poor I have been on welfare I have been
on state housing I have been on food
stamps my kids are still in
Medicaid I send my kids to private
school because that's what they need I
make it work I can tell you all about it
but I don't have time um my kid two of
my kids are going there now both of them
have specific needs they're doing
amazing she was not doing any like she
was not getting her needs met at public
school and the nothing against public
school it's just for my child and my
family it was not a good fit and as a
mom who's determined I was going to
figure out a way to make it so that my
children can become successful
independent adults in society um
I have so quick sorry I would love to
answer questions about lgbtq I would
love to answer questions about foster
care poverty special needs I can answer
all of those questions from last week
and this week um that you know people
have been wondering about so I guess
I'll just leave it at that thank you Amy
thank you very much Miss good Rich are
there
any hey excuse me Amy I got the Amy
right any questions for
Amy not seeing thank you very very
you okay next we have Brian balky I
believe we called him last week but he
was not available to speak and I hope
that you're there you go here he is well
thank you very much uh to members of the
committee and thank you Mr chairman good
afternoon um my name is Brian bulky and
I'm a resident of New Boston and the
superintendent of schools for sa19
proudly serving the communities of gtown
and New Boston Austin as a
superintendent I support a parents right
to choose the educational pathway that
parents feel is most appropriate for
their child I support individual family
decisions to homeschool to enroll in
public charter schools as well as attend
private schools including religious
schools I do not however support public
funds to be used to pay for these
educational Pathways simply put our
public schools are not properly funded
the state of New Hampshire does not meet
its constitutional obligation to fund an
adequate education the the
20192020 State per pupil average for an
elementary school student in New
Hampshire was
$7,150 in New Boston we spend
$2,791 this is the fourth lowest per
pupil cost out of16 elementary schools
we spend $4,400 less than the state
average that's 26% less even with this
low per pupil cost the local school tax
rate is projected to be over
$17.50 next year
approximately 21% of the residents of
New Boston are school age kids according
to the New Hampshire Department of
Education equalized valuation per pupil
report the property value that we have
for each child is
706944x
communities like gtown and New Boston
the state continues to not adequately
adequately fund our Public Schools this
has been found in multip multiple
lawsuits Claremont 1 Claremont 2
londonerry and many legal scholars
believe again with the current conal
lawsuit that was recently heard by the
state bo the state supreme court the
burden of local property taxpayers to
pay for public education continues to
hurt local communities I cannot support
any bill that uses state tax dollars to
fund education Freedom accounts when our
Public Schools continue to not be
properly funded and the state continues
to not fund the true cost of inadequate
education thank you for the opportunity
and I hope the committee does not
support
hb20 thank you very much superintendent
are there any questions from
one sure thank thank you very much Mr
chair and thank you very much
superintendent for uh joining us um uh
this afternoon uh you'd mentioned the uh
the tax rate in um the school tax rate
in um in New Boston uh could you say
what that is again we're projecting next
year to be
$17.50 and then of course the Statewide
educational property tax um which by the
way is uh local money that's raised
locally retained locally and um
categorized as state aid is on top of
that okay and would would uh would you
um um be interested to support a school
funding reform that uh would would
improve the Equity uh for students and
taxpayers and potentially even see a
property tax reduction in New Boston of
nearly $7 per thousand I
would would that be more in line with an
average well it's fasting um and with
all due respect to commissioner edel BL
when he testified last week he said that
school districts are spending
$20,000 so if that's the true cost of an
adequate education I would submit to you
that this committee and the house and
the Senate have a responsibility to
truly fund an adequate education and
right now that is not the case and local
property taxes are impacted local
communities continue to be hurt we're
driving uh seniors out who are on fixed
incomes and this is in a community that
has the fourth lowest cost in the entire
State thank you very much thank you very
Le thank you I'm curious as to um your
definition of a public education does
that mean the public funds schools or
does that mean that the public funds an
education for each child in the
state well the definition as a
superintendent that I would follow are
the minimum standards in Ed 306 which
clearly outlin lines all the required
elements that school districts are
required to offer to students so all of
those uh requirements along with the
federal mandates we have a significant
number of unfunded mandates that are
posed on our local schools that I think
are well documented within the history
of New
Hampshire thank you very much further
questions I don't see thank you very
much superintendent thank
you okay next we have uh Kim Spencer Kim
education on can you hear me now yes
okay thank you chairman for the
opportunity to speak today um my name is
Kim Spencer I live in Manchester I am a
former educator a former owner of a
large Child Care Center that served 150
kids a foster parent until we adopted
one of our foster daughters and most
importantly
I'm here today as a mother of seven
children you can say my life has been
about caring for serving educating and
advocating for children as I've worn all
these hats in my life I have come to
learn and I think we can all agree that
there is no one size fits all for
children not in the way they are raised
and certainly not in the way they learn
kids learn at their own speed in their
own way and in their own style and many
benefit from learning in different
environment
I was going to tell you about my own
personal experience but last week you
heard many stories on that I will just
summarize that you can't imagine what it
is like to raise a child who thinks they
are stupid and the amazing moment when
you find the right educational fit for
them and they look at you and say I am
smart I can learn I will add that a
child can feel this way in any school
district we used to live in Bedford a
school district acknowledged for being
one of the best and moved to Manchester
to be closer to and more school options
for our family last week as I listened
to the testimonies there's one thing I
noticed the arguments against the bill
are mainly about money and the worry of
dismantling the public school system and
the argument for this bill is mainly
about families and our wonderful kids
that we will continue to advocate for or
fight for because we want them to be
successful I will add that many of the
kids asking for scholarships and looking
for school choice as we heard from Kate
demerge this morning is because they are
being discriminated against either for
their special needs their colors or
their own personal
beliefs um I was educated by the public
schools and most of my children have
been educated by them but I've been
alive for 48 years now and for all those
48 years I have been hearing that the
public school system is not is
underfunded and not getting enough money
and that it isn't working as well as we
would like to because it needs more
money I'm beginning to think there isn't
enough money to fix them the school
system am I out of time I'm sorry yes
okay basically I just think that I to
summarize is just that this is s shows
us that the school system public school
system is currently not working and it
definitely is needing change and I think
this bill is a good start to it um and
will'll give parents choices thank you
very much M Spencer are you willing to
take
questions um yes but I only have a few
minutes because I've got two remote
Learners home
today are there any
questions well thank you very much no
questions have fun with your two remote
Learners thank
you
welcome uh next we have Ragnar Kemp um
please
okay honorable members of the New
Hampshire house education committee we
are blessed in New Hampshire to have
some of the best public schools in the
entire country but even the best public
schools don't work for outliers my name
is Ragnar Kemp a citizen of New
Hampshire since birth and I represent
myself in support of hb20 because I was
an
outlier my parents decided to homeschool
me because they two were outliers
however that plan was blocked when my
father died of cancer when I was just 4
years old after that we couldn't afford
it less than a year later I started
Public School a year early by standard
rogay I came home that first day of
elementary school and almost every day
thereafter asking why do I have to go to
school they don't teach me anything
there and while a few teachers were
Sterling exceptions and went above and
beyond that pattern otherwise kept up
until I graduated another year early
because I wanted out I was miserable
because the school did
not address my
needs and it's easy to look at my track
record of success since then and say
well he had public school he turned out
fine and that's technically true but it
hides something important it hides the
potential that was lost I look back to
my middle school years where I had my
nose in a novel instead of a textbook my
years in high school where I acted out
in boredom and frustration and my years
in elementary school where I didn't
understand why I was even there what
could I have been had I been able to
learn to my potential rather than a
syllabus that potential that let me
finish my Master's Degree before the age
of 20 and teach myself enough on my own
to pass 13 AP exams to be State AP
scholar where could I have gone if I had
started using that potential at age five
or 10 instead of 15 and more saliently
how do you teach the virtues of hard
work to a child who doesn't even need to
work to achieve good results let
children have access to the best fitting
education they can no matter their means
Public School may be available for
anybody but it's not for everybody thank
you thank you very much are you to take
questions I am yes okay for the
committee are there any
questions I don't see any hands thank
you very much
for thank you okay next we have uh
Heather H I am looking for Heather Hera
I don't know if they are the
same yes hi I'm on audio can you hear me
okay yes thank you all right a day a a
day and another day and a half later I'm
so excited I get to talk all right I
time this ready go thank you Mr chairman
committee for taking my statement I'm
speaking today on behalf of myself and
all the mothers and parents who need an
alternative way to educate their
children my name is Heather Hera I live
in Keen the Hampshire and I'm a single
mom my daughter is 17 and currently
attends 11th grade at high mowing School
in Wilton she attended um manano Walder
School here in Kean from 1 to eth grade
with the exception from homeschooling in
second grade none of that would have
been possible without the children's
scholarship fund mananc Walder school
will now be closing at the end of this
school year 2021 due to covid pushing it
over the
edge as well as it being a huge gap
between local pay and the cost of
private education here in Kean if I had
had hb20 available to me I wouldn't have
had to pay out of pocket for my
daughter's math tutoring and
transportation to her school I currently
have to pay $160 a month for her to take
a bus from Keane to Wilton hb20 would be
helpful for transportation purposes
which I have found nobody's really
mentioning the people that I have heard
that are opposed to hb20 like the lady
that just spoke always make it about the
money not about what is best for our
children my child has no learning
disabilities but I do believe in wal dff
education and they meet the child where
they're at also please take in mind the
lockdowns the lockdowns have been very
challenging I'm try not to
cry for our
children
suicide and depression
depression is at an all-time
high it's more important ever than ever
to meet the children where they're at I
personally feel public educ ation is
very
Antiquated I am a product of public Ed
public education I always felt like a
square fitting into a circle in my
opinion in uh public education was
originally developed to train the masses
quote unquote education is a personal
individual process hb20 gives us that
freedom after all we are living in the
Live Free or Die state in closing I will
share one of my favorite quotes you
cannot become what you want to be by
remaining what you you are thank you for
your time and please I urge you to vote
in favor
hp20 thank you thank you very
much thank you for your time are there
any questions from
Mr not see thank you so much
representative lad I'm going through
quite a few uh on the list from last
week and I'm not able to find a lot of
people here I was wondering if you could
ask them to raise their
hand
are there any folks out there in the
remote country that uh were signed up on
the previous time we
met2 uh if you did would you please
raise your hand by uh as an
attendee then we can address those okay
I do have uh winner Fred F finberg I'm
sorry I messed up where did she
go I think you dropped your hand so you
went to
the B of the list
okay oh there she is okay thank you hold
vber okay I think I'm
on yes can you hear me yes okay my name
is Winford fenberg I'm the
superintendent of seu 65 PS Regional
School District representing seven towns
uh in the lake sunpi um and kiasar area
uh committee members thank you very much
for listening to my
testimony um I would like to stress that
this is my testimony but it is also
uh testimony with the endorsement of the
uh Kart Regional School District and
School Board the board on uh February
4th has unanimous ly voted to oppose
this bill due to lack of accountability
negative impact on taxpayers in the
seven district towns and the lack of
transparency to the public I know much
has been said before I will try to stick
to my two-minute limit so I have
provided written testimony but I just
will focus on a couple of issues here
the bill takes public funds that were
generated by Collective Taxation and for
the purpose of serving a good a common
good and end verus the creation of
individual entitlements for anybody who
wants to spend Community funds on the
pursuit of their personal preferences in
no other area of Public Funding is such
individual spending Authority granted by
the state we build roads we build
bridges for all citizens to use we fund
hospitals and emergency services with
public tax dollars we support Social
Services child protection police fire
the courts with revenues local generated
by local County and state taxes nobody
in their right mind would endorse giving
State funds to individuals who prefer to
hire their own security detail because
they don't like the local police force
we don't distribute individual portions
of our court systems budget just because
some people don't like the rulings of
Superior Court judges and instead want
to go out and find themselves their own
judge and jury no reasonable Society
could successfully exist in this manner
and yet House Bill 20 does exactly that
its purpose is to replace the New
Hampshire public education system which
was funded by and for the communities
accountable to public elected boards and
constitutionally bound to provide an
adequate Equitable non-discriminatory
children done okay I you have my written
testimony um I just want to say one more
time that the school board in the seven
towns of the kar Regional District
has um asked me to represent them in
this hearing and I gladly do so thank
you very much for
your thank you very much superintendent
it's good hearing your voice again
you've testified many times before at
the committee we have yes thank you um
are there any questions for
Winfred I don't
[Music]
see we don't see any this time thank you
so much thank you for your time thank
you okay next is uh Jody Pon soles uh
Jody you've been promoted welcome to
education
committee hi can you hear me yes I can
oh thank you so much for um having me
speak today I have a child who's an
accelerated learner when he went to
kindergarten he was beyond board we were
both told he was not allowed to say
please challenge me um at the end of
kindergarten he was hit by a car and
acquired a traumatic brain injury with a
lot of neurological issues um the school
at the time would only give him a 504
plan which they did not follow I
advocated for one whole year for my son
to get the breaks that he needed books
on tape because he was unable to see
properly um to get rests that he needed
um everything I tried failed one whole
year I could not find an attorney in the
h should have helped me because the
schools retain them um I had no choice
but to pull my child out of public
school at the end of first
grade I was horrified at the treatment
that my child received from the adults
in his school from his
teachers I was horrified at the backlash
I received as a parent for bringing it
to their attention that not only did
they not educate him to his abilities
they failed him and his
disabilities
what would you have me do for my child
for his entire education
program continue him on that path or
give him the opportunity to flourish in
an environment that meets his needs and
that's where he's at right now he's
being homeschooled he has a tutor one
needed he has um a co-op he goes to and
I wouldn't be able to do this with the
children's Scholarship
Foundation um I think hp20 would be the
best route for my child situation to go
because he would get the physical help
he needed he would get the educational
help he needed to thrive um I just want
to say thank you so much for listening
to me and please vote for
hb20 um this is about the children this
isn't about the teachers it's not about
the unions it's not about anything other
than the children I see I'm out of time
thank you so much thank you very much
Jody are there questions from the
no I'd like to just thank her for
the thank you m thank you you're welcome
thank you
all okay next we have Sarah Scott Sarah
you've been promoted go ahead and speak
please uh thank you Mr chairman and
members of the committee uh my name is
Sarah Scott and I'm with Americans for
Prosperity but out of respect for the
committee's time and that of the parents
and children who are still waiting to
testify I will go ahead and just submit
written testimony and let you move along
thank
you see what other hands we have
raised okay next we have someone uh Jane
Jane I don't have your last name if you
wouldn't mind just letting me know who
please are you there Jane can you hear
me oh yes yes thank you my name is Jane
berson bulu and I'm the executive
director of the New Hampshire
Association of special education
administrators thank you for the
opportunity uh to speak with all of you
this afternoon I previously had
submitted my written uh testimony so I
won't uh go through all of it I would
just want to hit upon some of the
bullets uh that are in my testimony the
first one uh speaks to the uh lack of
accountability in regards to
hb20 um as many of you know um idea uh
requires school districts to uh be
accountable to some really important
issues things such as child fine
specific disciplinary practices is
reporting of restraint
seclusion uh expulsions there are very
specific requirements in regards to the
professionals who can provide services
in regards to their
qualifications um hb20 um none of these
procedural types of requirements are
spoken to um which really denies the
civil rights of of our students with
disabilities in regards to the fiscal
impact you've heard a lot about that
um with covid our school districts have
been severely impacted physically um
especially when it comes to special
education and students with disabilities
our association really feels as though
subsidizing our private schools with
public monies takes away from the much
needed fiscal uh monies that are needed
for our Public Schools I mentioned uh in
which allows for students um who are
placed in private or home schools to
simultaneously be able to attend uh a
public school for curricular and
co-curricular activities HB uh 20 shift
really strips the District of adequacy
AIDS and if a student uh with
disabilities and I see my time is up so
I will yield because you do have my
testimony but I did make comments
also on Parental placement and equal
access opportunities and would welcome
any questions that you might have for
me thank you very much Jane good seeing
you again
Sor winter I
know um are there any questions for Jane
from
the that's where yeah special education
administrators
Association um are are there questions I
don't see any nope thank you very much
Jane have a great afternoon thank you we
do have your testimony yes yes that's
what she said okay uh next we have
britley
promoted yes hi good afternoon everyone
thank you for the opportunity to be here
uh with you today my name is briy Bam
and I am the executive director for the
New Hampshire Association of School
principles I've also um already
submitted written testimony um which
included uh testimonials from close to
70 School leaders in all five regions of
the state so I hope you have an
opportunity to look at that um again in
difference to time and respect to
committee I I realize there have been
many Salient points already raised as to
the question question questionable
composition of the bill as it currently
um reads uh including ambiguous
definitions therein as already um
Christina Barrett from the Schoolboard
Association has raised um our concern is
as proposed this bill is more of a
limitation Act versus a freedom of
Education Act um basically ensuring
freedom for some but segregation for
most um and I think these points have
already been made by those who have
testified in opposition to this piece of
legislation I I also want to note that
um Barrett Christina and his testimony
referen the code of conduct and the
hopes that those in the private sector
would be held to that same code of
conduct I would like you to also please
factor in the code of ethics and taking
a look at that in Ju opposition to this
piece of legislation as it defines an
Educators responsibility to ensure that
they are respectful of an inclusion of
um all students regarding um Equitable
Services uh diverse meeting diverse
needs and working with all stakeholders
within um any school Community uh uh
much of that seems to be void of this
specific legislation as it stands um and
lastly um many points have been raised
about comparing the public sector to um
business and industry and yes as leaders
we are mindful um that there is place
for uh growth which we continue to do um
but there is research out there um in
Forbes Magazine Pew pole research Gallop
holes that educators are in your top
three or four most trusted professions
um when surveyed across the country so
again um for the reasons we've disclosed
um we ask that you consider voting an
opposition of the bill as written thank
you I'm happy to take questions at this
time are there any questions from the
principal Association through
Miss I got one is the New Hampshire
principales Association K through 12 K
through a Elementary and secondary
combined yes it is thank you okay thank
you very much thank you Mr chair I
believe we have one last speaker who's
raised his hand I I thought that he had
testified on this bill already but um I
can unmute him you
like we have two more
[Music]
education well it it may have been on a
previous bill but
I thank you very much Mr chairman and
members of the education committee uh my
name is Scot Ross I'm the business
administrator for sa19 I will focus on
the concerns that I have regarding
fiscal transparency and accountability
which I believe are lacking in this
bill on page five lines 35 through 37
they deal with Audits and unfortunately
the bills Tex provides little clarity
about financial audits of this taxpayer
funded
program there is no mandated requirement
to conduct an independent Financial
audit nor does this bill mandate the
percentage of efas or scholarship
organizations that must be audited
annually to ensure that tax dollars are
spent with the utmost
Fidelity secondly I respectfully raise
concerns with how taxpayer funds are
accounted for uh with Public Schools the
Department of Education requires that uh
business administrators like myself
complete very lengthy Financial reports
each year they're called the doe 25 they
take days to complete these annual forms
allow the state to calculate the cost
per pupil um expenses and they also
discern how the public schools spend
their budgeted dollars data from these
mandated Financial forms allows the doe
to perform fiscal analysis such as the
one created for this bill however based
on the text of this bill we're basically
saying that public schools will be held
to a much higher standard to account for
the expenditure of taxpayer funds and to
me that makes no sense
I hope that you as elected officials
would share in my concern that all
entities receiving taxpayer funded
dollars would be held to the same
standard of financial reporting if the
goal of this bill is to promote better
opportunities for New Hampshire students
than having the ability to fairly and
factually compare the financials of both
public and private schools that receive
taxpayer dollars ensures both
accountability and transparency so again
I would urge you to you just consider
the financial auditing and
accountability safeguards to protect
taxpayer dollars thank you thank you
thank you very much Mr brose uh are
there any questions for Mr
Bros Mr bro I have one um in working
with the Department of Education I find
that some departments or some school
districts are having their doe 25 forms
audited prior to sending it over to doe
does your District audit the 25 or
simply audit the entire District which
you are required to do for your assets
revenues and
expenditures that is an excellent
question uh both districts which I work
for we have we use audited results
meaning that our independent Financial
audit which is done are used to then
produce the doe 25 reports so it ensures
that uh a second set of eyes have have
looked at the financials which again
going back to my public to my comment I
just believe that if you're going to
pass a bill like this then uh then you
should have those same standards of
accountability and transparency because
when you do compare District to District
or school to school um you should be
able to compare apples to apples and
when I say that these doe 25 forms they
drill down to how much money you spend
on electricity to books to computers you
name it and it would be really nice to
know that when you're spending taxpayer
dollars that you know um and you heard
the testimony of of kids who are in
favor of this bill who they want a
computer well it would be good to know
where the money was spent and again
that's an administrative cost that
public schools have to account for um
which unfortunately in this bill it
doesn't appear that that level of
financial accountability and
transparency is there and and I'm asking
you to reconsider that thank you very
much superintendent thank you thank you
afternoon uh last speaker is Liz Canada
uh Liz you've been promoted welcome to
education good afternoon thank you
chairman and hello members of the House
Education committee for the record my
name is Liz Canada I'm a stepparent with
children in the exitor district and I'm
here speaking on behalf of myself I'm
here to express my opposition to House
Bill 20 and my testimony today will
focus on oversight and
accountability thankfully I think we can
find Common Ground yesterday morning
there was a tweet from the New Hampshire
GOP about a charter school that had
quote grossly misused federal funds
unquote one of the major concerns about
privatization as the GOP pointed out in
this tweet is the lack of oversight and
accountability issues surrounding that
specific Charter School have been
present for almost two years but because
of the lack of oversight and
accountability these issues seem
seemingly continued hb20 also lacks
oversight and accountability measures I
am curious how the representatives on
this committee will work to resolve this
significant concern especially given the
Republican party's recognition that
misuse of public dollars and
privatization efforts is already very
present in our state thank you for this
time thank you very much Miss Canada are
there questions
for
Miss not see Hands thank you very much
thank
you Mr lad repad there are no more hands
raised would you like me to go through
the rest of the document well what we
need to do is we need to ask those that
are in the queue or in the attendee list
is there anybody else that desires to
speak that has not spoken
before trying to get on but they had the
wrong number and so I don't know if they
now have the right number I tried to let
them know they they kept getting on and
getting an error because the number was
wrong I can't I all I
one just repeat it I guess okay for the
members that are those that are
listening in the attendee list is there
anybody there that wishes to speak that
has not had an opportunity
either today or on the previous day we
were discussing H20 if so please raise
your
hand
one Elma I'm not
sure of elma's uh last name but Elma
please there
yes
ELO you'll have to unmute can you hear
me now yeah okay um I'm Elma hignett and
I've been homeschooling for seven years
um and and it just amazes me how
everybody's also fighting for funds not
realizing that children are in need um I
I'm also a taxpayer and I've tried
sending my child to a public school and
not once have I ever received on how
she's doing um and I had to struggle
myself to find a place for my child um
being a firsttime mom and being a
firsttime adopted mom it was very hard
for me until today I don't know where my
tax money is going so I would like to
vote and would like for everyone to vote
vote for
hb20 thank you very much missman are
there
questions not seeing any hands thank you
very
much okay so at this point in time we've
asked and there's nobody else in the que
so we're going to close this
person uh as Asma l l
uni
Asma hello can you hear me now yes hi uh
my name is Asma aluni and I am a mother
of eight children who are now adults um
I have homeschooled two uh of my sisters
and so I understand the need um to make
sure that people do have a right to
homeschool their children but I'm
actually um speaking today in great
opposition to this bill because um
unfortunately our public schools are
underfunded and that is a big issue and
that's where we need to be focused on
and so I just um want to speak in as a a
mother who is someone who's homeschooled
and at the same time um I think this is
a mistake um when we should be focusing
our money on on our public schools that
moment thank you very much as are there
any questions from the committee see
thank you very much thank
you e l h u n
i
e okay I don't see anybody else at this
time we are closing the hearing for
closed okay for members of the committee
that concludes our work for
today um just as a notice we are meeting
on Tuesday Wednesday and Thursday next
week it's in the calendar I believe
those were all emailed out to folks um
yesterday and you should be in receipt
of them uh so you can look at those and
see what times one one of those days I
don't have right in front of me but
we're starting at 9:30 instead of 9
o'
morning Wednesday Wednesday uh the
Wednesday meeting will be conducted in
the
finance uh rooms which are the head of
the hallway here on floor
two so we will be meeting there uh to
discuss bills so once again uh thank you
very much for participating today and
are there any questions from members of
the
committee did you ever get the numbers
of how many people signed in we can get
[Music]
asking not to use a modern man well
according to the according to the sheet
this morning we
have uh
732 that support we have
3754 in
opposition nine neutral and 151 to test
oh I
think I'm sorry that is old list
let's okay I think today we added an
additional
375 in
support 1464
opposed to neutral and 35 people signed
up to
testify but to my surprise
a lot of them were not on the call so
those did we okay so it checks out okay
good so does that answer your questions
represent now we also have the
information from the previous day part
one which supported it 7:32 I read
that oh okay I'm sorry I just2 opposing
it was
151 and they all did did not
testify so um that's that's the
information which we have
questions thank thank you very much and
have a a good weekend